shocking new testimony from Hunter
Biden's partner Devin Archer yo get this
we all saw the video of Joe Biden saying
if you don't fire the prosecutor you're
not getting a billion dollars and what
we heard over and over again from
liberals was that but this was the
policy of the United States we now know
thanks to Devin Archer that Hunter Biden
and Executives from barisma called DC to
get this prosecutor fired because they
were investigating their company so
there it is laid out for you Devin
Archer also testified that Joe Biden was
on the phone with Hunter and his
business associates CNN of course is
trying to defend this thing it was just
the illusion of access despite the fact
10 percent was reserved for the big guy
that's the biggest news today but we
also have a lot of other crazy story
which is probably very big as well
Moscow hit by drone strikes the photos
and videos are shocking and now you've
got Oliver Stone saying he regrets
voting for Biden because Biden may be
starting World War III and then on top
of that I'm throwing this in for good
measure there's a a ridiculous article
about a UFO nearly starting World War
III by like taking control of missiles
but you know how much we love our stupid
distractions and then we've got the
story of a journalist
who was in Ukraine was arrested and just
recently got out and is on the run in a
long Twitter thread describing how he
was tortured this is a crazy story we
have to get into all of these details my
friends but before we do of course head
over to castbrew.com and buy our coffee
we sponsor ourselves Casper is our
coffee brand and we are launching our
coffee shop hopefully it'll be open in a
few months you can pick up all of our
new Blends like Mr bocus pumpkin spice
experience sleepy Joe decaf we also have
oh unfortunately stand your ground is
still sold out we were able to get the
pumpkin spice back in stock but the
stand your grounds medium roast sold
like hotcakes I suppose but we've got a
bunch of different blends when you buy
cast brew coffee at casper.com you're
supporting our show and you're
supporting us we basically get rid of
all the external sponsors for a variety
of reasons but also don't forget to go
to timcast.com click join us become a
member because we have a members only
uncensored show coming up for you at 10
pm where you as members can call into
the show and ask us and our guests
question questions and it's also just
not so family friendly can be a little
bit spicy so you don't want to miss
those they're good fun smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about this and a whole
lot more is Liam Cosgrove thank you for
having me guys I'm excited to be on long
time listener
um yeah I so if you probably don't know
me because I don't have a huge following
but I go to the state department I go to
the Pentagon I'm a reporter for the gray
Zone and I
um ask them questions and I you know try
to
um do the job of a journalist which is
hold uh the powerful accountable and um
you know not many people in those
briefing rooms seem to be doing that but
uh yeah thanks for having me excited to
be here right on we also got Phil
Labonte hello everybody my name is
philibonti I'm the lead singer of All
That Remains I'm an anti-communist in
the counter-revolutionary I'm Ian
Crossland what's happening everybody I
just dranked uh 1300 calorie Shake in
like 15 minutes that was pretty intense
never did that before
building that muscle I gained 12 pounds
in the last two weeks I think 10 of them
are permanent the other two might be
Waterway we'll find out I weigh 142 of
the show none of them are permanent keep
it up you got to keep eating he said you
gained 12 pounds at 129 I'm 142 right
now oh wow wow I actually started 127
because I'd cut weight for the music
video for the for the scene where I'm
like really emaciated so I went from 127
to 143. good job right now it's gonna be
like is that more weeks and Ian's gonna
be jacked that's that's the plan you
might want to slow down though because
12 12 in one week yeah it was five
pounds on Friday night and then five
pounds on Saturday because yeah like
three days worth of food yeah but that's
probably just like you put food in your
stomach and then weight yourself oh okay
what happened was I worked out all week
but I didn't and I ate you know 1800
calories and then on the weekend I just
loaded calories three times as much as
normal and then I put on is that good
like you felt fine yeah I felt pretty
good you should you should weigh
yourself at the same time every day like
like in the morning like after you go to
the bathroom so that way you're kind of
like in the same state like empty as
empty of a stomach as you can get and do
that like for a week or two and then you
get a really good idea I gotta actually
weigh as opposed to like varying because
of water I got a smart watch you should
use oh yeah yeah it's over there it's uh
then you can track your health and
fitness stuff okay it'll show you like
your heart rate and everything you can
monitor it we'll get it after the show
okay cool just just realize right now
but uh we also got surge here pressing
button yeah how much creatine you taking
man because that'll be about about 10
milligrams a day okay well I know it's
not a ton but yeah it's like it's like
two two segments of five milligrams I
think that's the the dose right now oh
okay you're taking the testosterone like
RFK no no I have not and that's
interesting I don't know if it's not
that far yeah yeah yeah it's all good
man you're looking weird is he not is he
not on testosterone am I off there he is
definitely on I thought all right okay
yeah yeah yeah okay okay I'm nervous
about it I thought I heard him say
testosterone I've heard that once you
start down you've got to keep doing it
if you stop that it can mess you up so I
don't want to start on something that I
can't stop okay
yeah but what you do is uh well my
understanding and always talk to your
doctor because I'm the nutritionist but
more fat in your diet and then they have
natural supplements that like there
there are things you can get that aren't
testosterone but what your body needs to
make testosterone that's pretty cool
bikini eggs and stuff anyways on
surge.com by the way uh yeah let's go
that wraps up the Ian health and fitness
show let's jump to the news we got this
one from Fox News ladies and gentlemen
this is probably the biggest bombshell
out of the Devon Archer testimony I mean
that's actually hard to say because we
know that uh in this testimony we
learned Joe Biden was on the phone 20
plus times with in these business
meetings while VP but this one is
shocking Devon Archer says Hunter Biden
and barisma execs called DC to get
Ukrainian prosecutor fired Devon Archer
testified for hours
Devon Archer testified Monday that
Hunter Biden topics X called DC in 2015
to ask the Obama Administration to help
fire the Ukrainian prosecutor
investigating the firm a source familiar
with his testimony told Fox News digital
and they lied but ladies and gentlemen
we got Joe Biden right here admitting to
all of it that was is the assignment I
got I I got all the good ones and so I
got Ukraine and I remember going over
convincing our team our brothers to
convincing us that we should be
providing for loan guarantees and I went
over right I guess the 12th 13th time to
Kiev and and I was going supposed to
announce that there was another billion
dollar loan guarantee
and I had gotten a commitment from
poroshenko and from uh yatsenyuk that
they would take action against the state
prosecutor and they didn't so they said
they had they were walking out to
Prescott said no I said I'm not gonna or
we're not going to give you the billion
dollars
they said you have no Authority you're
not the president the president said I
said call him
I said I'm telling you you're not
getting a billion dollars Jesus I said
you're not getting a billion I'm going
to be leaving here and I think it was
what six hours I looked I said I'm
leaving in six hours if the prosecutor
is not fired you're not getting the
money oh son of a I got fired and
there it is right there shout out to DC
Drano for that video which has been
circulating some time he reposted it
today so uh that argument we heard over
and over again from liberals that it was
just U.S policy to fire that prosecutor
now I gotta say that that was never
backed up by anything why why did the
U.S want the prosecutor fired so I I
argued about this like years ago
whenever this came out with a kind of a
mainstream liberal friend of mine and he
said what you just said he was like you
know the entire like everyone in in like
the U.S
establishment agreed that this guy had
to go and this kind of debunks that he
it's saying barisma gave him a call and
said no no so the impetus came from
barisma but this makes sense if you look
at barisma as an arm of U.S interests
barisma acting as U.S policy interests
called DC and says if you want us to
keep operating this guy's got to go
because it's investigating us so simply
put you could say it was U.S policy
there was a former CIA director on the
board of barisma as well as the vice
president's son so of course it was our
policy we were running the show
but when you get to the brass tacks of
it corrupt institutions which were
enriching people's private interests
called up their buddies in DC or their
dad and said this guy is getting in the
way to 10 for the big guy so we've got
Tony bobulinski this is one of the under
Biden Associates saying out right he's
in on it you've got the emails 10
percent held by by what does it say HB
for the big guy is that what it said was
that was that barisma though or is that
the China thing 10 for the big guy I
think was a China deal my point
specifically though is we can see in
these business dealings there is
evidence that Joe Biden is personally
benefiting we also the text from Hunter
Biden where he said something the effect
of dad taking his salary or things like
that so he's acting as a proxy for Joe
Biden while Joe Biden was in government
Joe Biden personally goes and gets the
prosecutor fired who was investigating
the company where his son was getting 83
000 a month there it is Devin Archer
testified before Congress and and and
the huge thing so so but also real quick
like if you just watch that clip and
just like like listen to Joe Biden's
tone in that clip like it's like like
he's just like acting like he's like
talking to like his nephew he's just
like bro like I don't know
brazenly bragging he's just like he's
like I gotta leave in about I gotta
leave in about six minutes you know I
got a flight to catch why don't you fire
that guy he's like he sounds like a like
a mafia guy who's like proud of like
that's just probably it really does
sound like a line written for like a
mafia movie yeah he's like he's like
listen Joe if you don't fight a guy in
six minutes
yeah he's like talking just
publicly that's about what Trump was
impeached over that speaks to the way
that that politics in Washington DC is
handled generally though I mean or I I
would believe that would lead me to
believe because he does he doesn't think
it's a he doesn't think it's a big deal
exactly it's no problem it's very normal
for him it comes off as you know as you
know obviously this is the case this is
this wasn't the first time that he
behaved like that or whatever so I mean
it it it does speak to the the the tenor
and the way business is done not just
with Washington but obviously
internationally as well and the U.S if
the U.S has one of the less corrupt
governments on Earth which I don't know
for sure if it does or not but I know
there are places that are a real mess
but if if the US does have a less
corrupt government and that's the way
that business is handled uh among you
know someone that was the vice president
who'd been in in DC for 45 years at that
at that point or whatever then you know
that just imagine the rest of the world
yeah the rest of the world's a mess and
you know Ukraine is an absolute pigsty
because everyone knows that Ukraine is
is ex well everyone is aware of the the
root the the story or narrative that
Ukraine is one of the most corrupt
governments in the world 100 and and I I
don't know but I would assume Russia is
too but like
um that that's why you know it's it's so
crazy that like were involved in this
war in the first place because we're
talking about two very corrupt
um very authoritarian which we can get
into like you know pre-war zelinski's
authoritarian Tendencies but um like why
the U.S seems to think it needs to have
a dog in this fight of like
you know why do we care which corrupt uh
oligarch rules over Crimea or the Dome
boss it's like we shouldn't really care
they're both like horribly corrupt uh
countries to begin with but what's
interesting from this stuff and then
there was Chuck Grassley on the on the
senate floor uh the other day who talked
about one of these um I think barisma
Associates or one of Hunter Biden's
Associates in Ukraine had recorded
um 19 phone calls 17 with Hunter Biden
two with Joe Biden for the purpose of
blackmail this was Chuck Grassley saying
this I don't know if he produced any
like documentation for it but um you
know so and and why that's scary is like
could our president be blackmailed into
supporting this war
um yes and and and the IDE and and World
War III is a real risk from this war so
like the implications of like I mean
it's Russia is not viewing this as
Russia versus Ukraine they're pundits
all their personalities are saying NATO
versus Russia so they're very much
viewing this as International conflict
and it's only the most naive or the most
duplicitous individuals who say we are
not at war with Russia we absolutely are
you don't get to provide weapons
training military and volunteers and
then be like but we have nothing to do
with this war
yeah no and I agree and and it's even
worse because like I I think it's still
a majority we can maybe pull up the
polls if if they're up there but like
how many Americans still support
um the Ukraine war and I think it's a
majority and obviously these people
think you know we're fighting for
democracy we're fighting to protect
International borders but like if the
truths were to come out that like now
we're fighting because like they have
dirt on Joe Biden
and the the like we're literally risking
the entire world and they might have
okay there's the this is a Gallup from
one month ago 62 in June 2023 support
Ukraine reclaiming territory however it
is going down slowly slowly going down I
mean
um yeah I mean I I I I I I think
hopefully what would bring that bar to
the left
um more would be you know educating
people on the real reasons we're at War
and I don't know if it's because did
they have blackmail and Joe Biden no it
could just be geopolitical like
you know uh
you know Videocon it is very much
wanting to gain access to energy right
for Europe to expand the European
economy economy is stagnated if you can
supply weapons to Ukraine to damage
Russia's military that's good for the
U.S but uh but I don't know but yeah
they say that but I don't get why that's
good for the U.S like why why is like
why is that an end why is weakening
Russia which by the way means killing
like young men on the battlefield why is
that an end to the US and I I once
um I was on I don't know if we published
this but I was on
um Capitol Hill and I asked this to Dan
Crenshaw he was like Hey we're you know
we're weakening a strategic adversary
and I was like well why why are they a
strategic adversary and he was just like
oh you're pro-russia I'll see you later
and it's like no I'm just like I don't
want to blow up the world because
they're a bricks Nation they want to get
off the U.S Petro dollar they want to
create their own rival currency they're
starting to and the US views that as a
big threat Russia is the easier Target
out of the bunch China is too large so
in the meantime NATO expands presence in
Europe gains more control bolsters the
European economy to compete with the
Chinese economic Bloc and Russia being
the easier Target goes after them right
now but the funny thing is they didn't
used to be in bricks and they didn't
used to be trying to get another
currency like why were they our
strategic enemy ever I don't understand
after the Soviets fell it was like let
us go back in time I'm my friend yeah
let's go to 1993. what the hell's going
on yeah you keep going back it's never
just because the Soviet Union collapse
doesn't mean that these sentiments and
the people there were their worlds
changed for a lot of people the world
did change don't get me wrong but for
powerful individuals political leaders
and the oligarchs who are seizing
control they were born and bred of this
World East versus West so you can go all
the way back and keep going back in time
to find where the dawn of conflict
emerges but U.S interests competing with
foreign interests and the U.S has been
in many ways losing this in a lot of
ways and I think a lot of it has to do
with
there there is the fact that being a
constitutional republic weakens Us in
terms of uh executive action
the Chinese Communist Party snaps their
fingers and they get things done they
build a bridge overnight why because if
you don't do it you get locked into
Gulag or they're you know but then they
also build a bunch of empty apartment
buildings that have to get torn down
because you know Central planning
uh is you know it's inefficient or it's
you know it can you can you're at that
you're at the um sure but they're
talking about ghost cities they're using
a combination of the two they have so
this is this is an interesting uh merger
between the total communist
authoritarianism and having a little bit
of low tier low level economic activity
be allowed so this results in some kind
of capitalistic growth but you have got
to be a member of the party the party's
got to be in fascism your company yeah
essentially right yep so the US I would
say you know my view of Joe Biden or any
of these presidents save Trump in my
lifetime it's the intelligence agencies
that are running everything and I think
it's fairly obvious and the way we've
always described it and even for Barack
Obama is that he's like when I get an
office we're gonna bring our troops back
and then as soon as he gets into office
he sits down and they go Mr President
and they slap the documents in front of
him and say this is why you'll do as
you're told and then anybody who says
otherwise they just slide a picture of
JFK right up and say once again this is
why you'll do what you're told so I do
think that I think the intelligence
agency is behind the scenes first most
of what we think we know is probably
wrong the news we're reading is probably
wrong come on we know they lie all the
time and we're still we're still trying
to base our perception on this war off
of all of this stuff and what Joe Biden
is doing I do think the people at the
CIA and the FBI want the us to win and
would prefer it if all of our lives were
better however in terms of conflict we
are just asked on a battlefield we are
economic numbers so Freedom doesn't
matter our rights doesn't matter the
Constitution doesn't matter all that
matters is the the global sphere of
influence for U.S and Western interest
but even if you're like you're at the
CIA and like you think in these terms
and like you you know you want to
maintain the petrol dollar which which
makes sense why you want to maintain the
Petra dollar
um
but but the risks like they don't think
of the risks of like like why is the
Dome boss
worth risking nuclear war
um if you're the CIA
um
like it it could give Russia carte
blanche access to the Black Sea through
Crimea but if they if they really
solidify it that means that they're
gonna make turkey become their Ally and
that's a threat that turkey will leave
NATO because turkey is the exit from the
Black Sea into the Mediterranean turkey
if Turkey got out of NATO yeah it would
be it would be it would be that would be
the end of everything if Turkey leaves
NATO and joins bricks I mean we were
basically bifurcated the earth into two
hemispheres why do you say that well
because turkey control the phosphorus
yeah what they control the Bosphorus
they control the straight into the
Mediterranean from the Black Sea I mean
that's tons of economic activity for
Europe that will be can that is under
control of turkey so long as turkey is
working with NATO we have that Advantage
yeah but I mean I don't feel just having
just having meat turkey not in NATO
doesn't mean that turkey automatically
like will shut off the canal no no I
mean if if Turkey sides with bricks if
Turkey does say to the West you are now
on on the
let's just say the not nice end of the
stick
that's going to put more pressure on us
the issue with you know what I when I
look at Ukraine we got to go back and
the place I typically start and it goes
back much further than this obviously is
the cutter turkey pipeline Syria
the U.S and our interests in the Middle
East obviously were a conflict between
the U.S and Russia I mean even going
back to the mujahideen the support of
these groups so that they could fight
the Soviets Etc we are still in there
for very similar reasons why is it that
Syria falls into Civil War how
convenient for the United States when we
were facing obstruction for from Bashar
al-assad all of a sudden the country is
collapsing well we want to build the
pipeline pipeline would have gone to
Europe offset Russia's gas prom Monopoly
would have helped bolster energy energy
and expansion economic expansion in
Europe all of this stuff ties together
you then it's no surprise that there's a
counter-terrorism official from the CIA
a director who is now on the board of
barisma an energy company Hunter Biden
joins that board it's U.S interest to
stop the prosecutor investigating it
this is all about I think they're
looking at hard energy expansion
economic numbers they're saying we want
x amount of growth over this many years
they're looking at it like Russia is
growing at this pace China's growing at
this pace they're working together if we
do not not have X amount of growth they
take over thucydides trap world war
three we lose Chinese Communist Party
wins okay but like so if you take a step
back even if you're still at the CIA
looking through their perspective and
you take a step back and you look at
like how things have gone over the last
like 20 years with all of these you know
regime change efforts we we undergo we
spend like trillions of dollars and we
just completely destroy these countries
that we were hoping to kind of control
and then you look at Afghanistan like we
we pull out anyway so it's like but
you're missing a bigger picture we don't
have a good track record do we do we
destroy the countries that agree to our
control
uh no the countries that bend the knee
and kiss the pinky ring we never hear
about invasions or coup d'etat or
anything like that because they did as
they were told it's the countries that
defy the us and not just the U.S but
Western powers that face these you know
we came we saw he died is that what
that's that's how Hillary Clinton
described it about Gaddafi yeah you know
so a reason will be made and the people
who don't fall in line do as they're
told well oh so what I was going to say
is like
if because you kind of said the goal is
like control and money
um which I guess are two different
things but if like if they just wanted
money if like this if like
the people at these defense companies
and and you know CIA wherever want money
it's like why don't they just
I mean like we spent we spent well I
thought you said that but I economic
expansion right they they want to see
the sphere of influence of Western
Nations expand and maintain a unipolar
domination in the planet on the planet
on Earth
China is pushing that boundary and we
are we are now Mo very likely I think
it's safe to say we are a multi-polar
world meaning we now have the rise of of
multiple superpowers which brings the
very real risk of of mass competent war
after World War II we saw the rise of
the liberal economic order the intention
was to prevent this from happening again
you know they tried it with the League
of Nations United Nations they want well
okay so on that point they want they
created it to prevent this from
happening again but now the evidence
seems overwhelming that like it's the
driving force for why it's happening
again always and so it's there's no
there's no there's no simple answer to
this exercise is has been like difficult
for me because my brain does not work I
imagine like any of these people at the
CIA but like why they need to dominate
and influence the entire world when it's
like look at like look at this amazing
land mass we have over here on like you
know the Western Hemisphere it's like
why can't we just like enjoy this and
live on our farm and like take it easy
especially these guys at the top and who
have all the control and I agree but
they've made the argument very clear
China will not stop they're trying to
take the South China Sea they're
building military bases on these yeah
but they're not going to come here
they're not going to come here well but
what about Alaska what about the
aleutians it's a question of will they
come here or will they expand their
influence into Africa which they're
already doing South America that's like
the Belton Road initiative and then all
of a sudden in the U.S we are
constrained and can't get access to
certain resources that is their View and
they say it plainly I'm not saying
they're right but they've made their
argument but also Belton Road is like in
like military bases like Belton Road is
them like you know getting countries in
debt which you can say is like Western
model right but yeah but but I mean like
they're building infrastructure or
they're like influencing them to like
you know on International to vote with
them on International organizations but
like they only have like
um I think they only have like two or
three foreign military bases and they're
like artificial islands near China we
have military bases all over that's what
I'm saying is like why are we so worried
about China when they don't yet have all
these foreign military bases that's why
because they're expanding it's kind of
like but not militarily but they are and
you're saying it's a small number but
that doesn't matter what matters is they
are that's it the intelligence agency so
we have troops in Taiwan we have troops
in the Philippines not an article but
it's like why do you think they're doing
it maybe because maybe we could talk to
them and say hey guys don't build this
base on this artificial Island we'll
pull our troops out of Taiwan you know
what I mean the you so negotiations
could happen to prevent it as opposed to
like right right but you're not making
you're not making an argument it's this
it's simple there's a unipolar power
structure where the West controls things
through economics and through conflict
and those that don't fall in line
Hillary Clinton we came we saw he died
that's what happens China starts
expanding Russia teams up with them this
is a threat it doesn't matter if they've
if it doesn't matter if the guy across
the street threw one rock at you the
moment he does you call the police and
say I will not I will not stand for this
now you can argue that the guy with the
rock through to the guy who's got 17
tanks and a bunch of RPGs lined up but
either way they're going to be like oh
he's throwing rocks at us right China is
expanding in certain areas their
influence is growing their economy is
growing it is a threat to the U.S we are
now facing a multi-polar world and the
the the the these uh I I view it like
after World War II you get the liberal
economic order you get these powerful
Elites who are like we are going to use
this position to control everything and
prevent this from happening they pass it
down to their kids Next Generation Who
start to slowly screw things up who pass
it down to their kids who have no idea
what the hell they're doing and have
fumbled the whole thing and now we are
facing a a massive crisis but these
people inherited this they don't know
better so they're just thinking we
better fight this war to prevent it from
happening somewhere else and you're like
okay well look there's two outcomes I
suppose the parent tree is
we do nothing the acidity's Trap
dictates the likelihood of World War III
is tremendous and then War happens or we
just start it all now pushback and hope
that holding back Russia from the Don
bass and putting pressure on China stops
the expansion and we don't end up in a
thucydides trap yeah I I you know I
don't I I I don't I don't see well in
Ukraine specifically like do you see
Russia well certainly not Crimea I think
there's no shot Russia leaves Crimea
there's two million Russian civilians
who live there and then and and it's
it's basically been Russia uh we had I
think it was Dave Smith but they I think
it was Dave Smith who mentioned Russia
didn't invade and take over Crimea yeah
they stepped out the door of the
military base and said hi guys I think
like three people died or something but
it's not that the point is that they
already had a military presence of them
I know so they didn't they it was that
they walked out of the military base and
said how's it going everybody we're
right I think they've actually had that
base for hundreds of years that's right
um but so
it like and then hope I just hope
there's people in the U.S who like
understand that and are like oh yeah
we're just waiting to play that card of
like nobody knows
what do you mean you you go talk to the
average person average liberal look man
no no I'm talking about people in the
top brass yeah the the challenge with
those who support all this is that you
go and ask any liberal who's waving a
Ukrainian flag and they won't be able to
tell you the first thing they can't
point to Ukraine on a map yeah I mean
that that yeah that I mean that was the
whole Dan Crenshaw thing of just saying
I'm pro-russia when I tried to ask him
you know what it's just like it was like
the war with Iraq and an invasion of
Afghanistan it was like are you with the
terrorists are you with us it's like
dude you want to invade a foreign
country and kill their leader I got
questions and they're like well then you
support the terrorists no shut up yeah
but that's what they go for because the
average person doesn't care doesn't want
to care and doesn't want to pay
attention they want to they want to play
their games they want to watch their
shows they want to see Taylor Swift they
don't want to deal with this stuff yeah
I don't blame them and I will give a
shout out to Dave Smith that that bar
that was we surge pulled up earlier with
the with the poll going slowly to the
left I think Dave Smith has been doing a
fantastic job of um describing the
history of this war to people and
disseminating it so shout out to him
let's jump to this next door we got from
the postal millennial I love this we
have testimony that Joe Biden is on the
phone with Hunter Biden and his
Associates at the same time we have
testimony from one of Hunter's
Associates that Joe Biden is getting
Kickbacks and then CNN says Hunter Biden
was selling the illusion of access
because Joe was on the phone but Joe
wasn't talking shop
does he need to
seriously if they're sharing bank
accounts sharing email addresses if Joe
Biden is taking a son's salary
it's like the mafia it's like the guy's
talking negotiating a deal with the
other guy and he's like listen the Don
says he wants you to do this or else and
then they're like oh I'm not going to do
anything and then all of a sudden the
Don walks in the front and goes how's
these guys doing and they're like oh
everything's good man we're doing
everything you ask and they run away
see they may they're trying to make this
claim that makes literally no sense the
moment you put Joe Biden the phone it's
a whip crack the vice president is in
the room well don't you forget it so I I
hear your point and I agree with it but
also I I that claim is just not true I
mean this is um this was in the New York
Post the other week of of when
apparently there's a text from one of
the Barista Executives and he says to
Hunter can you ring your dad question
mark and then Hunter
um
placed him on speaker phone and uh sorry
this was not a text this must have been
a call
um he but hunter goes on speakerphone
with Joe Biden and and says these guys
quote need our support so I mean he
wasn't just selling the illusion of
access he was putting these guys on
speakerphone with his dad and and
telling his dad we need to help them so
where is that from that's from New York
Post
yes I think it's fair to say that CNN is
desperately lying and what is the scene
at Oracle look like I'm actually curious
to see how they frame that other than
post millennial
think this is it former business partner
says Hunter illusion of access to Joe
Biden yes former business partner says
Source says that is so ridiculous
that's hilarious
four business partners
a couple Degrees of Separation I'm
surprised they published that possible
deniability right there
yeah we know
um it is like Tim as you were doing your
mafia metaphor it's like if the if the
mob member was like hey we got a job for
you but before you go you're gonna take
my son along like how is that not Mafia
interference with the kid the guy's son
the mob member's son he's bringing his
son along for the game
this crackhead is all of a sudden invite
along the son of the boss goes to uh
like a bunch of guys who are delivery
guys or you know drivers or meals or
whatever and it's like I want you guys
to move all this product my dad wants it
done they go your dad doesn't want this
done this is your job you're trying to
Upstate you just like gets on the phone
says Hey Dad how you doing and then his
dad's like everything's going good son
he's like yeah I'm here with the boys
they're saying everything's good right
boys so he didn't talk shop but come on
well we know exactly what that was well
but I
yeah I agree like even if you're doing
that it's still up but like that
isn't that isn't even what Biden was
doing like Joe is clearly more involved
than that what's like the dirtiest stuff
he was doing do you have the data on on
the quotes or like any any specific the
specific like the three most corrupt
things that he did that we have like
documented proof of or extreme amounts
of evidence well I guess I don't know
like you know policy like which policies
arose from it I just mean like the text
um I don't know if there's anything that
originates actually from Joe but just
like the text that Tim referenced
earlier of Hunter saying
um you know you know pops he's like he's
talking to his nephew or his daughter or
something he's like pops takes 50 of all
my I'm not gonna do that to you
when you get older so I mean like why
would Hunter lie about that you know
what I mean like that so it's in private
texts yeah exactly and so that's one
example
um I guess we don't have here from New
York Post how Joe responded to these
guys need our help but oh oh but there
is a timeline this so this was like
it was like
um it was like a matter of weeks later
that he gave that speech we played and
he got the guy fired
um so yeah I mean the timeline lines up
as well like Dad these guys need our
support week couple weeks go by uh I
lost prosecutors fired I love that
they're like Joe was on the phone with
Hunter's Associates a couple dozen times
for no reason yeah he didn't talk shop
it's like wait wait two dozen times on
the phone with these guys what were they
talking about going golfing or is that
what Joe was or Hunter was Joe was on
the phone on speakerphone over 20 times
with Hunter Biden's Associates that's
what Devin Archer tested oh wow so the
question is like for what reason it's
like it's not a social yeah exactly
which is all which is another reason
that CNN article is ridiculous like did
they include that fact in there like it
was kind of just the illusion but also
they were on the phone two dozen times I
really do feel like unless the Democrats
decide that they're gonna replace Joe
Biden for uh
running for president as the candidate I
don't think that there's anything that's
going to happen no matter what the
evidence comes out no matter who says
anything because I think Merrick Garland
is is incredibly corrupt I don't think
that he's gonna I think that he's he's
gonna protect the bidens as much as
possible and and it's it sucks to be so
black pilled but really I mean
the evidence is overwhelming that that
it's worth having hearings about and and
you know you can barely get and
Democrats don't even want to you know
hear hear the the evidence so I I just I
hate the fact that I'm black pillar at
the beginning though that you think they
are going to replace Joe Biden no no I
said unless they're going unless they
start to really like wind up uh Gavin
Newsome or whatever okay I love it I
love that hairy Sisson guy because he's
like 20 but he's got the education of
like a third grader and I'm not saying
to be mean I'm saying quite literally he
tweeted out that uh I was at Alito
Supreme Court said that uh Congress has
no authority to regulate them and he was
shocked by it and I'm like bro we
learned that in like second grade it's
called the branches of government
they they're they're all equal branches
of government they have no power over
each other they have degrees of power
over each other for checks and balances
that's about it but he really doesn't
get it and then he recently posted a
photo I bring him up because he posted a
photo of Joe Biden looking horrifying
and he was like he looks so cool it's
like dude how much did he you know I
gotta be honest if you're like dark
Brandon if you're a gen Z dude and
you're following that guy and you agree
that flabby skipping leg day Joe Biden
is cool looking oh I'm sorry man the
hairy Sisson thing's interesting it's
him and his buddy they just kind of
appeared out of nowhere and they're like
these young kind of good-looking like
young guys and they do that frenetic
thing where they do this a lot like a
dash do Broski thing but it caught on I
guess it's like a meme yeah I was just
trying to find the clip now there's a
hilarious one where he's just like
frantically like he doesn't take a
breath and and it's he's just talking
but it's hilarious but what I think your
point about those guys show the you're
putting them come on that'd be fun but
your point about those guys coming out
of nowhere I I think like I think a
hundred percent
um those guys would not have a huge
following if like the right didn't just
make make fun of them all the time I
think that's main
all their followers are the right making
fun of them so but on purpose that's why
I see them they're doing that on purpose
the right doesn't want to prop up the
most articulate liberal speaker they
want to prop up the worst and most
pathetic liberal speaker so then they
can knock them down but blow them you
know straw man yeah basically be like oh
look at this guy in his arguments yeah
you know if there's someone who's very
calm and makes a well-reasoned liberal
argument nobody's gonna be outraged they
might respond and be like I think you're
wrong about this and they'll send a link
and then that no one cares right but you
find someone who is genuinely ignorant
of the facts but screaming about
nonsense and you're just like this is a
spectacle yeah this is but do you think
Harry Sisson is doing that on purpose I
think he's getting paid to do it yeah I
I think that paid by who he works for
some well he works for some talent
agency not directly he works for some
talent agency that gets funding from
certain Democratic groups so I've seen
reporting oh okay and he he gets paid to
post I mean that's my assumption based
on the news report I could be wrong but
it's clout building okay everybody but I
thought you generates followers is going
to make money from doing it okay but I
thought you were saying like he's
intentionally being stupid and ignorant
because he knows it'll rally up the
conservatives but so then why would the
DNC pay to like embarrass themselves
with a guy like Harrison someone said
they were smart but it's but but I think
you're you're thinking too absolutely
right there are people who post things
intentionally stupid because it
generates attention I post troll posts
and then the media takes them serious I
once said impeach the queen and I had a
whole article written about Tim Poole
journalist calls for the impeachment of
Queen Elizabeth before she passed and
I'm just like what it was a joke I can't
believe they didn't impeach her yeah but
they're like each the queen possibly
[Music]
I don't even remember why I said to
impeach her like she had something had
happened I guess she was not woke enough
I don't have no idea you know but yeah a
lot of these people on social media they
uh
just say utter nonsense to get followers
that's a good observation you were
saying that people will retweet or
repost like the cringe stuff because
it's so bad you're like you want hey
everyone I want you to see how horrible
this is so you know what you're up
against but I see it and it's like I
just feel like you're that guy talking
to me when you repost him so like I have
to unfollow people when they repost
trash content to make fun of it I don't
I don't want that trash content in my
life I understand the mentality of like
yeah and then you're awesome and then
you're also like you're you're
convincing yourself of like a caricature
of the left that isn't true and then
you're not prepared like if you want to
debate the left you're not really
prepared on what they actually believe
and then like also in like your everyday
life you might know like I most of my
friends and family members are like left
wing and so if like if I if I look at
Harry Sisson and I'm like oh but then if
I get in a real conversation with like
my relatives I I I'm gonna be like
unprepared I'm gonna be like oh they're
actually a lot smarter and like I should
I should you know I don't know it would
be obviously better than everyone agree
I certainly think Harry Susan is a
caricature of liberals who's like it's
shot content but his understanding of
reality is about on par with the average
liberal voter they could not point to
Ukraine on a map and there's varying
degrees of this but I got to tell you
man I agree with that the the the the
the key moment a good example is when we
had Hunter Avalon on this show and I
said in one example that Joe Biden said
if you don't fire the prosecutor not
getting a billion dollars and he smugly
said that never happened and then I
played the video and he was like uh
whoops it's like dude I don't I don't I
don't care for debate like in this idea
that we're gonna stand on the stage and
hit a buzzer and be like well I have an
argument and do different debate tactics
that's stupid I care about hear the
things that I think here's why I think
them if you are wrong I will say you're
wrong I'll pull something up if it turns
out I'm wrong I'll say oh I was wrong
about that right I agree but that's that
is a debate that's like the point of it
but my point is I have no concern or
fear of debating a liberal on any of
these issues at all and I don't think I
know everything about these issues I in
fact think I'm mostly wrong because
you're open to discovering the truth the
Deep State the intelligence agencies are
not giving us the true and correct
information about what's going on but
what I can say is I've read
substantially more about all of this
than any of you and I do believe if the
average if you took an SD card and
neural linked it all the basic news
coverage of Ukraine and Joe Biden into
the head of the average liberal they'd
vote Donald Trump instantly
it's just that they don't know they
don't want to know they watch CNN and
that's about it
or MSNBC and they believe people like
Rachel Maddow who who's nearly in tears
When Donald Trump isn't indicted as a
Russian spy they may not vote Trump but
they'll definitely not vote Biden they
vote Trump I'm kind of that guy I just
I'm not I don't immediately go to the
opposite part about that or RFK if you
downloaded all of the information on the
Biden family
Ukraine and the war the Obama
Administration just all the news
articles Hillary all her details yeah
into their brains they would just be
like now I understand why everyone's
voting Trump a full red pill full red
pill but if you go to a trump supporter
and you were to download them to their
brands all of the news articles about
Donald Trump the unfor the the the thing
is most Trump supporters would be like
these are contradictions this is the
point if you were so my favorite uh two
stories from Politico one that the
Democrats were uh that Ukraine said that
there were Democrats trying to interfere
in the 2016 election or something effect
then you have a several years later
Politico reporting once again that in
fact that was Russian disinformation but
never retracting or correcting their own
reporting saying otherwise how can
Politico run two stories one making a
claim and one saying that claim was
Russian disinformation without
correcting because it's garbage nonsense
now the fact that I know those two
articles exists gives me some Keen
insight into what's really going on in
the world especially considering who the
journalist was who wrote the second
article you put those articles into the
minds of the average person and they're
going to be like something's not right
here Trump supporters already know the
news contradicts itself and lies all the
time many of these liberals just believe
Rachel Maddow and they think Fox News is
lying granted not a big fan of Sean
Hannity you know but Tucker Carlson was
pretty good but they just read garbage
from like The Daily Beast and then
believe things that aren't true I
remember when I got red pilled it was
the most depressing probably the most
depressing experience I've ever had in
my life it was like near suicidal like
the way I gave up on life when I was
like this really is all fake all not all
but like this is whole American Dream
thing is like fed to me over on the
backs of slaves really let me pull up
this story from the daily basis a good
example Joe Rogan says it's a fact that
January 6 was a false flag cites Ray
Epps now that's a misleading headline if
I've ever seen one but of course that's
The Daily Beast if you are someone who
only consumes garbage nonsense like The
Daily Beast you might think Joe Rogan's
this crazy Alex Jones guy
however fortunately for Joe Rogan he's
like one of the most famous people on
the planet and many of his fans know who
he really is these mirrors they don't go
very far but let me read this for you
they say wildly popular podcaster Joe
Rogan once again pushed baseless the
baseless conspiracy theory I loved it at
the January 6 Capital interaction was a
false flag orchestrated by the by the
federal government adding that pro-trump
rioter Ray Epps clearly instigated the
attack now hold on there a minute Ray
Epps is on camera
the night before and the day of telling
people to go to the Capitol and go in
the building he's then seen whispering
in someone's ear and he's on the front
line as the people breach the capitol
grounds
curious they didn't go after him the
feds didn't go after him he was
protected by the media defended by the
media and even now they're trying to
obfuscate what he did it's fascinating
isn't it earlier this month ABS sued Fox
News for defaming him this we know and
in that lawsuit we're hearing the Epps
may actually be facing criminal charges
they're going to mention that Rogan's
got a concert with Spotify blah blah
blah
Rogan said the intelligence committee
had a vested interest in this going
sideways adding that if somebody wanted
to disparage a political party or to
maybe have some sort of justification
for getting some influential person like
Trump Offline that would be the way they
would do it and Joe Rogan is completely
correct he was talking to Jim Gaffigan
who did not know anything about this I
gotta tell you when I listen to Joe
Rogan talk to Jim Gaffigan you know I'm
a political guy like I sit here I read
all this news I am just like shaking
wanting to talk to these guys you should
get gath again on the show and be like
ask me any question and I will answer it
and I will show you all the sources I
will pull them up one at a time and you
can by all means not believe the
guardian or NPR the New York Times just
you gotta have some standard do you
believe results or not do you believe
political or not okay well that's what
we're basing this off of but Jim doesn't
know anything he doesn't know anything
about it so what did Joe Rogan really
say
he said they never went after Ray Epps
he's seen on camera instigating the
stuff makes you wonder and now we know
what he said was a fact is that there
were guys there who are uh intelligence
assets encouraging people or I should
say I should say some kind of government
agent or law enforcement this is not
controversial this is confirmed yeah
they're admitted to doing it to going
let's go let's go hey go go and pushing
people towards the capital oh is that
admitted that agents pushed people
towards the capital there's there's body
camera footage of people who associated
with law enforcement I'd have to pull
this stuff up I'll be very careful here
because I want to make sure we're
getting it right but they're saying
things like go go go when questioned I
think it was uh the FBI said we cannot
like answer were there people involved
at all yeah yeah they pled the fifth
basically and I I did see that clip and
that and and Joe I Joe Rogan cited apps
and he cited you know the FBI director
pleading the fifth
um but yeah it was like early on there
was like very early on after Jan six
there was a New York Times article and
it was like federal agent you know
describes his experience on gen six so
um it's long been acknowledged that
there were federal agents in gen six I
think the strongest uh an argument for
false flag though is the pipe bomb which
apparently they have footage of like the
guy who put it there and they apparently
know where he lives to they've they've
like I I forget where I heard this but
they they know his address and yet they
have not
um prosecuted him or you know explained
what he whether it was a pipe bomb or
not you know what I mean they they it
doesn't look like they've investigated
what that was well that's scandalous
because that guy's like yeah Thomas
Massey has been posting about this and
that is that is kind of piece of in my
opinion that's like the most compelling
evidence because the bombs that were
placed around the capitol heightened the
entire situation to such a level that
you might be able to justify bringing in
federal troops or putting detaining
people without without charge or trial
Jim Gaffigan makes a good question he's
like why didn't Trump call anybody in
why didn't Trump just say get law
enforcement down there right now I think
it's fair to say that Trump was bumbling
quite a bit I don't think Trump had any
intention on anyone going into the
capital I think he genuinely had no idea
what's going on and I don't mean that he
didn't know there were people storming
the capital one side and going in
another I'm saying he did not comprehend
the situation well have you you've read
though that apparently after his speech
he told Secret Service to drive him to
the Capitol and they said no we're
taking you pretty sure that was a fake
story oh was that because they claimed
that Trump like attacked the driver well
yeah it was exaggerated that he attacked
the driver but what I what I garnered
what I gathered from that was like if
Trump did actually want to go to the
Capitol and talk to these guys could
have been a totally different outcome if
Trump was there and he was like hey guys
we want to do this peacefully as he was
probably still speaking when they were
breaching the capitol grounds oh okay
right but either way if he had gotten
there he you know he could have ended it
um and so it's weird that secret service
would say no we're not letting you go
and it's weird that Trump couldn't
override that with just a direct order
also so you know yep I got personal
criticisms I mean I wasn't the president
president had held a job during covid
man but the way he didn't send in
federal troops during the Riots of 2020.
President did a hell of a job during
covet well no you think operation Wars
no I don't think he did a good job I
mean the president has a hell of a job
during something like that is what I
mean and he so I can't talk too much
about him and like be like well if
I was there I would have this and that
because like backseat driving to
hindsight's 2020. but he didn't send in
the troops day one of the 2020
insurrections whatever the hell these
these Street riots that broke out after
George Floyd death I would told Tim the
next day like where the National
Guard what are we waiting for this is
going to spread out of control this is
like a fire burning right now and it did
two days three days later two days later
the city's starting to get burned down
and I'm like where's the president of
the United States the armed chief of our
military commander like
and it probably I think he was so afraid
of being called a fascist he didn't want
to invoke he didn't want to bring the
troops in and then the same so where
were the troops I want to make sure we
get this in the segment this is an
article from wlos.com an FBI informant
embedded within the proud voice on
January 6 identified in the record only
by the name Aaron testified for the
defense the witness said he was not
aware of any plans with a proud boys to
invade the U.S Capitol building so
that's one simple example we then have
this this is a filing uh this is a
defense writing the doj recently
disclosed involvement of undercover
office informants from other agencies
aside from the FBI and D.C metro police
at least 40 undercover informants so
that was one of the big stories there's
there was another uh there were another
couple videos that came out and uh you
guys should definitely fact check me on
this one it is hard to do because most
of the corporate press ignores this
stuff but there were a few videos from
law enforcement who were shouting things
like I think the video in question was
let's go let's go keep going keep going
or something like that
well that's fascinating because that if
that's true then that that's kind of the
Crux of the whole false fact false flag
claim so if that's true then Joe Rogan
was in fact correct well no no the
question Joe Rogan asked whether or not
the possibility of a false flag could be
and whether it made sense and it
certainly does make sense they used the
Insurrection thing for two years just
screaming non-stop over and over again
on TV that it was an Insurrection and
now the speculation is they'll try to
use this to get Trump removed from the
ballot so certainly there was a benefit
to all of this they deleted Trump's
tweets calling for peace they deleted
Trump's Facebook posts where he was
saying I don't think they they suspended
him Trump had said things like everybody
go home we respect law enforcement they
Shuffle that away and then claim he was
calling for violence
um you know if you're a commander and
you've got us your capital is under
siege by its own civilians like in their
they're starting a riot or they're
starting thing like you've got a few
options you know you can bring out the
guns and try and turn them down that you
can ask beg them to stop which doesn't
really work against large crowds or you
can insert well active do like Duty
Officers into the crowd to break it up
from inside that's one of the smartest
methods Joe Rogan points out the WTO
protests in Seattle they called the
battle for Seattle they had agent
provocateurs there we we've seen videos
there's a lot of speculation all the
time about agent provocateurs there was
one story in Canada where protesters had
military style boots started acting
violently the left has argued this for a
long time they conveniently forget the
possibility when it comes to the right
why they're happy it happened you had
the gravela Institute tweeting in
support of January 6 except for the fact
that factor that was right wing they
actually tweeted that it was good what
happened it was just bad that it was
conservatives or right-wingers that were
doing it they like it when it comes to
agent provocateurs the left will tell
you to your face the government stages
fake activists to incite violence for
the purpose of discrediting protest
movements then when the right is
protesting the left says I have no idea
you're talking about
and here you are yeah you can make the
same argument for election fraud as well
yep yeah we need people to stand up for
the rights of other the people you don't
agree with like if you see maybe it's a
big ask but if you see your political
opponents under duress and they're being
treated poorly or illegally you've got
to stand up for those people yeah you
need to stand on Principle as opposed to
a certain degree there's a certain
degree there is no there is no history
there there's no evidence of that
happening from really from either side
but definitely from the Democrats for
the past 15 20 years and that's why I
say to a certain degree because perhaps
when the country is Unified but there's
partisan bickering you get angry when a
when the doj is weaponized against a
political group you say hey guys you
can't do that unfortunately right now
we're in something substantially deeper
than that and now the question is when
they're trying to destroy you do you
provide them with your support yes first
time my life I've ever been in a
situation like where they were in the
50s where they were really afraid the
Communists were going to take over the
country so they were like the was a
jagger Hoover's Blacklist or whatever he
like start blacklisting all these people
that had communist ties and people were
losing their jobs and their careers and
like maybe if they hadn't done that we
would have become a communist election
so I don't know do you know that uh
Communists are excluded from the Civil
Rights Act yeah
uh yeah I think I didn't know that this
is still true to this day and I got
questions about the legal uh merits of
that it's in the law and it's not I do
not believe it's been adjudicated so I
wonder what would happen if you were
just like no Communists allowed this is
just this is like I I don't have any
kind of evidence it's just my my
impression but the in the 50s in the Red
Scare and stuff and I really need to go
and do more reading about like what it
was actually like
um but it really seemed like the people
that were really opposed to Communism in
the in the 50s and 60s it seemed like
they really understood that the left the
the international left has a fundamental
different uh understanding of the world
I was listening to uh this book called
uh this audiobook called explaining
post-modernism by Stephen Hicks and one
of the things that he talks about is the
way that
the way that the left doesn't have the
same kind of foundation that the right
does and it's about you know liberalism
versus authoritarianism and you're not
going to be able to find common ground
with people that have a fundamental
different understanding of what the
truth is or what reality is and and if
there is no truth then it's fine to use
ad hominems and call everybody Nazis and
stuff and we're seeing the effects of
that now it's it's been
20 or 30 years the well 30 or 40 years
now actually that the left is called
everybody on the right a Nazi and every
president's a Nazi and it always goes to
the absolute worst where you know
there's a lot of people in America now
that aren't unfortunately that are not
so afraid of the word of being called a
racist anymore you know they're just
like well you call everybody that you
call everybody Nazi you call everybody
so it doesn't matter and they'll that's
something that we have to deal with and
I don't I don't see how we can deal with
with the the struggles that we're having
as a country if if we can't even agree
on what the philosophy that the United
States is is founded on but hold on but
hold on because what you you're giving
credit to the people in the 1950s and
you're kind of saying well they were
actually good intention and they were
actually against Communists and pro
Freedom I'm only saying that maybe they
understood better than the average
person now I'm not trying to give them a
undue credit but then you talk about the
difference in ideology which is one is
uh collectivism one is individualism and
I agree I'm a big individualist but when
you go on this like Red Scare campaign
you're immediately dissolving one of the
crucial things of individualism which is
like one of the ones until proven guilt
yes one of the the flaws or one of the
the greatest challenges that liberalism
has is liberalism accepts the arguments
of opposing viewpoints as if they are
coming from liberals right so you if you
enter the disagreement expecting your
your the person you're having a debate
with to be honest but they're not going
to be honest you can never or come out
you can never have a a fair exchange so
that's one of the things that liberals
have to figure out how to deal with and
that's why that's why liberals and
that's why the Communists say liberals
always choose fascists over Communists
because the only way that you can fight
authoritarians is with authoritarianism
right but then you become like the
monster you're trying to fight like it's
what Tim said with like the original uh
purpose of like these International
bodies and then the grandchildren just
forget what the purpose was like look at
what the FBI is now look at what the CIA
is now yeah but how could you say that
they were always that way
yeah and if you look at J Edgar Hoover
they were always that way so I I just
don't think there's any Credence to this
argument of like we need to embrace into
our terrorism to get rid of no I'm not I
didn't say that we need to embrace I
didn't say we need to embrace it but I'm
I'm saying that
the current problem that we have is that
liberalism doesn't have
a it doesn't have a mechanism for to
deal with it
but it does like the price only
supporting liberalism and not supporting
other ideologies fair enough but the
point the problem that that we're
experiencing now is authoritarians lie
to liberals Libs bad liberals they
lie to Libs and Libs believe
them because what the what the
authoritarians are telling the Liberals
sounds good but so the tool then is is
education and it's very difficult
obviously especially with Echo Chambers
but to me that's the only viable tool
and that was another Jefferson quote
something about educating the masses is
like how to secure Liberty a lot of
times with tone because the data itself
doesn't convince yeah and another shout
out to Dave Smith because I think he
does that extremely well let's uh yeah
he is so good at that let's jump into
this super a political love loves him
he's so funny let's jump to the story
from NPR we love NPR guys a drone attack
on Moscow briefly shut one of its
airports and injured one take a look at
this photo there was a video I played
earlier we don't have it pulled up right
now where it's a guy driving down the
highway and he's just filming this
destruction on this building and it is
terrifying stuff they say Russian
authorities say three Ukrainian drones
attacked Moscow in the early hours on
Sunday injuring one person and prompting
a temporary closure for traffic of one
of the one of four airports around the
Russian Capital it was the fourth such
attempt at a strike on the capital
region this month now I saw some people
on Twitter claim this was a secret
government uh office that was protected
by Russian Security Forces perhaps that
makes sense I don't know why else they
would strike the target they're they're
going to go after military targets
but this is now escalation of warfare
into civilian capitals into Moscow this
is
I think there's we're starting to see um
a real case for this expanding well
beyond just a Ukrainian conflict it's
already now in Russia and where else
could it go next as is spreading there
was a news report that a Russian strike
was 600 feet from the Romanian border
which could theoretically
launch this thing just dramatically out
of control
and the Romanian NATO country
I don't know about Romania
um well so I will say so I was at State
Department today and serge it's not on
Gray Zone yet but you can maybe bring it
up on the state Department's uh YouTube
channel
um I asked him about this drone strike
and and timed your point of life Romania
is as of tomorrow Romania is in NATO uh
no as of 2004 August 1st to 2023 are you
sure it says 2004 post Cold War
enlargement says alphabetical list of
NATO member countries and it says
Romania 2004. this maybe this is a typo
that's weird oh no no it's saying that
as of tomorrow Rooney is a NATO member
but it has been since so far sorry to
interruptly okay no worries
um so yeah I asked the state department
about this and and to your point of like
did Ukraine do this I mean it was fairly
obvious so like an hour after uh this
drone blows up uh zielinski made a
statement and he says quote gradually
the war is returning to the territory of
Russia to its symbolic centers and
military bases and this is an inevitable
natural and absolutely Fair process so
zielinski said that and he's explicitly
said we're targeting symbolic centers
um which to me I could only mean you
know areas where civilians gather so it
sounds like we're targeting civilians
and I asked the state department this
and um he basically said well I don't
know if that's what symbolic centers
means and then he brushed it off and
wouldn't let me get a follow-up in but
um to me when you make a speech like
that an hour after the explosion happens
that kind of looks like you're taking
credit for it
um and so it's extremely scary I mean
it's crazy that the US I mean we keep
like U.S officials keep saying like well
we don't support attack we don't support
attacks on Russia's border well it's
like well you keep funding them and
arming them to do it so at what point
are you gonna like you know enforce your
um lack of support for attacking
Russia's border and um you know it's
just scary I mean this war gives us
civilians on the ground in Ukraine and
the U.S providing weapons which end up
in the hands of many of these people
like Russia knows full well what's going
on when it comes to this strike on
Russian targets Russia's not going oh
those ukrainians are at it again they're
saying NATO just attacked our capital
so this is this seems like the only path
the only path forward is going to be
escalation it could be a false flag
could be Russian drones doing it doesn't
matter either way the same thing happens
if it's a false flag then Russia wants
to escalate and it's even worse but if
it was a false flag why would zielinski
come out an hour later and basically be
like hey we're going after symbolic
centers I guess
um you'd be like if you were the
commander and then some random elements
within your country bombed some random
elements within the enemy country you'd
be like see there you go American great
yes let me bring you back to the era of
piracy where there would be privateers
and corsairs who would receive letters
of Mark from their government to disrupt
the enemy's supply lines and then let's
say it was the English and the French
the French would capture a pirate ship
running Black Sails or whatever a black
flag and then these guys are clearly
British they'd go to the crown and say
we know that you are ransacking our
trade lines how dare you we would never
condone piracy all the the oh I am
offended that's what they do so what's
going on right now it is the most
annoying thing everyone these officers
are like the yours is not involved in
war those are volunteers I'm like shut
up
it's effectively the same thing no one's
Stu like you can believe whatever you
want to believe so that you can sleep at
night but I assure you Joe Biden Kamala
Harris Milly whoever it may be is under
No Illusion that we are not involved in
this they know exactly what they're
funding and Russia is the exact same in
the Vietnam War it was the Americans
versus the Russians basically right
versus the Russians and the Chinese
maybe but for somehow we just never came
to blows with Russia we never even
talked about it as if it was against
Russia we did we call the proxy war yeah
they were funding the Viet Cong in the
North Vietnamese U.S Middle Eastern
involvement was proxy war
against uh very much so Russia and to a
certain Chinese yeah that was yeah
against the Soviets and that's what
that's what Syria is our support for the
rebel groups it's because Syria would
not side with us because they're allied
with Russia so of course anyone in
government a lot aligned with Russia we
opposed so convenient I'm like did Isis
was there were they funded by the
Russians
like you would think if the Russians
were really our enemies they would have
been funding Isis remember that
happening this is why they were happy
when Trump decimated Isis when Trump
started taking them out Putin's like
this is good yeah
it was good for both and then they
claimed that the reason Putin didn't
invade Ukraine was because Donald Trump
was catering to Putin's interests and
I'm like yeah
destroying Isis not getting us involved
in Wars wow it's almost like he was
doing with the American people yeah well
actually and he armed Ukraine with a
bunch of weapons too so that's true
which is obviously not in Russia's
interest
um there was also a tweet on this
explosion this account tweets it out and
they're like oh my God drones hitting
Moscow how unfortunate and then like a
little sunglasses emoji meaning like you
know we like this and then the General
Michael Hayden who's the former director
of the CIA and NSA former tweets out
tweets out oh it's an act of God like
about this explosion there's like you
can watch the video there's like this
woman who's screaming she's in Terror
it's like a horrible video to watch and
the former um director of the cin NSA is
like celebrating this on Twitter it is
it is insane of course
um I I don't it's like that shark attack
where there was the shark attack and
people were like happy because some
Russian dude got eaten by a shark but
who has nothing to do with the war it's
like
um people who don't realize that it's
the government's perpetrating these wars
and like you know most of these soldiers
are conscripted anyways it's like
you should be mad at the governments
even if you um you know believe uh the
whole narrative around Ukraine you
should be mad at Putin and the
government you don't don't celebrate
like civilians getting bombed in Moscow
what do you think what do you think is a
just solution to the war I I
um I mean I I think the war could have
been avoided in the first place by
um giving up uh or holding referendums
in which by the way zielinski campaigned
on this
he campaigned on holding referendums in
the Doane bus in Crimea because there
was like a decade-long civil war in the
Don moss and of course Russia basically
controls Crimea and and this Civil War
was awful and so in poroshenko's um by
the end of like by zelinski when he was
campaigning in 2019
poroshenko's approval rating was so low
because of this war it was like people
didn't people didn't want to fight this
war and and that's why also the azov
Battalion which is kind of the the
Neo-Nazi sect
um grew you know so much stronger is
because people didn't the only people
who wanted to fight were those guys
but so zelinski campaigns and he's like
I'm gonna hold referendums in the dome
bus I'm going to let them decide whether
they want autonomy whether they want to
secede or be in Ukraine and he wins
overwhelming he wins like 75 of the vote
and in the East everyone voted for him
in the in the general election
then he gets in and he doesn't do it he
seemed open to it you can actually look
there's like oh there's like Biden 2021
White House statements where Biden is
like saying like no no Crimea is Ukraine
we're going to stick to this in zelinski
earlier had been like well I'm still
open to referendums there but then Biden
makes gets involved and it's like no no
crime is Ukraine
um Boris Johnson was sent in and crushed
a piece yeah that was after the war but
so in terms of like a a a peace
agreement could have been
just hold referendums in the dawn bus in
Crimea Crimea overwhelmingly even by
like U.S government conducted polls in
2014 Crimea overwhelmingly wants to join
Russia the Doan boss it's not clear
whether they want to join or secede or
want more like just governing autonomy
um from Kiev
just just hold those referendums and see
what happens that that was Putin's
demand before he invaded and you could
have just granted that and people say
like well you can't do that because then
he'll just be even closer and he'll keep
going but it's like take the chance on
it then at least or or like negotiate
some I don't know negotiate something
better but like
like the idea that this counterfactual
is like well Putin would have gone even
further it's like well guess what like
hundreds of thousands have died Ukraine
is destroyed and millions are now
refugees because like of that
counterfactual that you're so sure of
it's like we could have held these
referendums and we and we potentially
could have avoided the entire war and we
still could we still could do that now I
think if Donald Trump gets elected the
day they call it for Trump the hour the
minute the war stops
yeah I mean I think he would probably do
maybe some form of what I just said I
don't know I just think the moment they
say and the winner of the 2024
presidential election is projected to be
Donald Trump Russia immediately says
ceasefire and zelinsky too would be like
finally the dogs are off my back I can
do what I want with my country like if
so maybe I think some of the dogs on his
back are kind of the far right guys
within his own uh within his own
government but Putin stops right away
because he wants more leverage so Putin
is probably going to be saying Trump's
going to come in he's going to end this
we're not going to get everything we
want we'll get enough of what we want
but if we're still fighting it's not
we'll gain more leverage by stopping the
fighting right now then and then you
know uh brushing up to to Trump's ego
and being like we knew that as soon as
you got in you were going to be
reasonable and help us end this conflict
so we pulled our troops back Trump's
going to be like absolutely here's what
I expect it's over 100 I mean I think
that's true of not only Trump but I
think that's true of RFK and vivec as
well
um agreed
um but I I also think like Trump winning
is just a massive a fantasy I mean I
think
um
we I I can't recite like the whole
history I know I know a couple
interesting facts about the whole JFK
assassination and to me it's
overwhelming that the CIA killed him so
Donald Trump won in 2016. well he won
and then you know
um the intelligence agencies
um well I guess Hillary and and her team
fabricated the dossier and then
um this kind of they tied stones to
Trump's feet exactly and and but but if
you if you think do you really think
he's going to be allowed in with like
the stated goal of like getting revenge
of the deep state or do you think they
might just pull the trigger at some
point well I don't know about any of
that I mean rfk's talked about the risk
you know based on his family history so
perhaps and there's been other people
who have speculated horrifying things
may happen but uh
look if if I believe that if Donald
Trump is harmed this country implodes
overnight
I mean it it's it's chaos Beyond chaos
if something happens to Trump in that in
that capacity not an option well I think
what's terrifying about that when you
take a little left would believe it the
left would be like yeah people hate
Trump no but that's why that's why
you're so correct it's like the left
would believe it they'd be like yeah
everyone hates Trump of course someone
would assassinate but the right is gonna
be like yeah exactly and then it doesn't
matter right that's gonna cause chaos so
you you have to ask yourself why the why
the United States has not say
assassinated Julian Assange when Hillary
Clinton reports I said can't we just
drown this guy and they're like yeah
he's in London right why
certain people they got no problem with
maybe it's a 16 year old American
citizen Barack Obama's life we're gonna
blow him up because his dad's a
terrorist so they kill Abdullahi in a
civilian restaurant in a country we're
not at war with Trump killed his son
though too Trump killed or his uh his
daughter his daughter now see
hypothetically I don't know that that I
that is a claim made by the family
whereas the Drone strike on a swimming
restaurant is confirmed by the U.S
government and another thing that's it's
one thing to catch around in a gun fight
and it's another thing to have someone
shoot a missile at like the daughter but
investigate Trump yeah fine I don't care
if this is collateral damage and an
American girl died he's responsible for
that yeah presidents should be allowed
to get away with this stuff especially
when we're not at war with this country
but uh but fair point right you know
Barack Obama was like blow him up whoops
he I mean Barack Obama had his actual
kill list like list of people but they
claimed they were targeting a different
guy and he was an actor was it whoops we
got the wrong guy but you know
convenient wolves but yeah yeah you know
so I don't I think
if something happens to Donald Trump
this country gets ripped apart in two
seconds and the reason why they don't go
after people like Julian Assange is
because they don't want to make Martyrs
you you will make that man Immortal and
only in his best features yeah yeah I
feel like they'll be some behind the
scenes Shenanigans to keep him out of
office before an assassination for that
same reason he's too powerful
metaphorically I agree with that I'm
just saying if there's a chance he's
gonna get into office though
what I find fascinating I think is that
Roseanne says there's not going to be an
election
and I had to ask her to clarify because
Michael Mouse said of course there will
be
but I think it's probably a mix of the
two perspectives there will be an
election but no one will care no one
will accept it no one you think 2020 was
bad 2024 is going to
be it's just gonna be nuts it's gonna be
bad because now after 2020 you're gonna
have every single Trump supporter
filming everything you are going to have
a hundred times as many videos coming
out showing weird things that may be
innocuous maybe nothing or maybe
suspicious
and no matter who wins or who loses the
other side will refuse we saw the Boston
Globe story where powerful Democrats
suggested the West Coast secede from the
union event in the event Donald Trump
gets elected that's how crazy they are
now what do you think happens if Trump
loses again
this time there's going to be people
everywhere filming literally everything
I thought 2020 was going to be more
chaotic than it was
Maybe I'm Wrong about 2024. but I just
don't see anyone accepting the results
yeah I mean you know I'll settle for
making it to 2024 and as long as you
know we do not blow up the world in
Ukraine or over Taiwan if that ever
happens so let me let me pull up this
story from the Daily Mail check this one
out JFK director Oliver Stone says he
made a mistake voting for Joe Biden in
2020 because he fears president will
start World War III with his support for
Ukraine
there you go he said quote if we don't
stop this what Biden is doing this guy I
voted for him I made a mistake I was
thinking he was an old man now and then
he would calm down that he would be more
mellow and so forth I didn't see that at
all I see a man who maybe is not in
charge of his own Administration who
knows it seems that he's dragging a
stupid Lane to a confrontation with a
power that is not going to give this is
their borders this is their world this
is NATO going into Ukraine this is their
whole other story he's right imagine
what would happen if China went into
Mexico and took large portions of its
government and started putting troops
and sending weapons the U.S would go
nuts I just saw no the U.S and we did
because we there's literally I just saw
a a tweet by someone that was talking
about uh Chinese uh police stations here
in the U.S policing the Chinese people
yeah bio labs and stuff here in the US I
don't think that the American people I
really think that as much as there are
people that complain a lot on the
internet and stuff I really think that
Americans are way too comfortable to get
really really Buck Wild and in like some
kind of revolutionary way they'll get
out in the streets and they'll you know
throw rocks and stuff and and throw
molotovs and try and get into fights
with the police but that's only the most
mentally
questionable or or at risk if you want
to call them that
um people that the average people your
average person has even the people that
have it bad have it better than most
humans in human history I just don't see
the the Revolutionary energy that that
what's your point though with China you
just mean like the fact that people are
not angry about it yeah there's Chinese
you know there's they're they're talking
about building a Chinese uh listening
Post in Cuba there's actual Chinese
um
I guess government police that are
policing Chinese
uh former Chinese citizens
there's HIV and China's done the same
thing in Canada they violated if the
United States actually took the Monroe
Doctrine seriously anymore there would
be there would be at least some type of
retaliation between all this stuff that
we talked about that we've mentioned in
the past five minutes or whatever and
the the Spy balloon that went over and
stuff uh
I understand that most Libertarians are
like you know we shouldn't be looking
for for problems with other countries
and I agree
when you got a country sending a police
force into your borders and policing
citizens of your your country from a
foreign country I get it that you your
anti-war Libertarians but hey at some
point the the the actual sovereignty of
your country matters even if you have
open borders well so I agree and I get
like we should be moderately upset about
those things but I think on this on the
scale of like I agree there's no
revolutionary energy but like I I'm way
more concerned about like this war we're
talking about what Roger Stone's talking
about about blowing up the world like if
there's a Chinese police station in my
local city
um that is pretty weird and concerning
but I'm much more concerned with like my
president potentially being blackmailed
by Ukraine and then therefore looping me
into a nuclear war that could literally
kill me one day
um where the Revolutionary energy needs
to be focused and and I agree there's a
lack of it it could simply be blackmail
that Hunter Biden's on the board of
barisma Dad Evan Archer calls DC says we
want the prosecutor fired the the the
the Elites in the oligarchs the people
in Ukraine know exactly what Joe Biden
did and then they call him up and say
we're gonna spill the beans unless you
give us what we want yeah no I I I I've
like gamed that out in my head as well I
think it could exactly be that and it's
just crazy and you know we should all
come together as a country and just say
Joe whatever they got on you it's
totally fine we're not going to judge
let the blackmail come out we'd much
rather I'd much rather see a naked photo
of Joe and like it's not that well it's
going to be evidence it's going to be
felonies right no I know multiple I was
going to say with addition I was going
to say like a naked photo of him with a
kid but like let's just let that come
out and just end the war man it's more
important support pardoning Joe Biden to
end the war yeah or just in general just
even preemptively with no expectation of
anything after would you
um I don't
uh with just for no reason
assuming that there's gonna stuff is
going to come out later is why my reason
would be but would you do it not with
any expectation or like tit-for-tat just
be like no oh would I do it right now
hoping like the war hoping there is
Black Mountain hoping the war ends or
yeah or for any reason would you yes I
would yes for any reason yeah I see I
see what you're saying yeah I would do
it for that reason
for no reason well you're not really I
can't tell if you're saying no reason I
mean if there's no reason I'm not as
concerned with the reason I'm just
asking if you would do it
there are reasons where I would do it
and that was one of them but if you have
I think if it is
all these pardons that we got to do I
see no other way forward if you have
been partying no you have you have a
tribunal if we know for a fact that he
was engaged in illicit activities then
he is criminally charged if if you have
no need to Pardon him if you have the
pardoning power you simply just indict
him
you could do that indict and then pardon
him why would you pardon him
so that we don't have this Tit for Tat
so that the Next Generation yeah for you
Hunter's sister doesn't come back with
guns of BL you know you don't want to
just keep the cycle 100 sister yeah I
mean I wouldn't be worried about that
but yeah I agree in terms of like for I
mean don't agree with the idea that by
allowing Elite criminals to get away
with their crimes you actually stopped
the crime well what you do want to do is
expose them and make the world know what
they did but then pardon them but if
yeah if you expose them and they and the
world knows what they did and then you
pardon them that is not going to
disincentivize people from doing the
same in the future I don't know if
anything can disincentivize it yeah all
the incentives are in their favor
Guillotines well yeah but that didn't
work well in the French Revolution
because like who's in control the
guillotine like who's deciding the guy
ultimately got his head cut off yeah
that's right not just him but you know
there's the threat of force I mean the
threat of force is usually the go-to
like how do you stop corrupt leaders
from being corrupt if it's divorce and
if it's treason there's varying degrees
of punishment
well I I think but I think I think on
some level you can like it's not only
doesn't only have to be punishment and I
guess Ian what you might be getting at
is like you can appeal I I imagine in
theory like you can appeal to the
humanity of these people like I know
like you know Lindsey Graham to me does
not seem like a guy who has much
Humanity in him
um Joe Biden I mean that hugely Brazen
corrupt kind of that Mafia display is
like is awful but like when you also
listen to that clip of him remember when
that that clip of him came out of like a
voicemail on Hunter's phone and he's
like son I love you you know we'll get
over this drug addiction or whatever to
me that sounded like
um I guess Dad who loved his son so I
think I think that's naive it's naive to
think like I can use I can like I can
like tap into that
um Humanity of Joe Biden but I'm just
saying it's there and he feels love for
his son
um
but but but yeah and and maybe there is
some way to tap into that like I don't
know if that's what you're getting at
with the pardons but
um I always won't solve it so what
I'm just saying one day and says like
God you know I do have these
grandchildren and like I don't want to I
don't I don't want to blow up the war
what I don't want to blow up the world
because I want my grandchildren to live
a nice life I I hope that deep down he's
thinking something like that I'm not you
know I'm not gonna Bank on it but I'm
hoping it's there that that sentiment no
I think he's more thinking I will burn
the world to the ground before I lose
power you think Biden thinks that way I
think he thinks to a certain degree that
way I don't think he's the most ruthless
guy ever he's he's bit he's just a
corrupt guy but these people tend to
have an attitude
corrupt individuals are corrupt because
their attitude is usually the whole
world will burn before I lose I don't
know if he's that strong of an
but you've heard like that nobody
with a Biden hot Mike quote from him
no when was that I I forget I think it
might have been at the DeSantis presser
he had but you guys really think he
thinks that much at all well that yeah I
mean that's another one just because
he's old now doesn't mean he did not
build his life and his family off of
these ideas that he will take whatever
he wants right this is look you wonder
why it is almost every every politician
is a bad person it's because good people
don't have what it takes to manipulate
everyone around them to gain political
power
right that's a good point and and and I
got I I do have that naive streak in me
because I got to be honest so before I
was into politics like during the
coveted era I barely read the news at
all and um I I like liked Anthony fauci
like I would watch the news and I was
like you know I kind of like this guy
like his raspy voice he's kind of
charismatic and and recently I um read
the real Anthony fauci by Robert F
Kennedy and it was mind-blowing to see
like when you when you learn about
everything in that book from the whole
like AIDS pandemic and how like the
chemo drug that they were prescribing
was basically causing AIDS or making it
way worse
AZT and him experimenting on Orphan on
orphans like killing hundreds of of
Orphan children and debilitating many
more when you realize that that guy can
go on TV and like Smooth talk the entire
world
um smooth talk like it's kind of what
Tim is saying and it's like Jesus like
that's a level of like psychopath that I
can't even imagine
indeed must you think like the
psychopath to defeat the psychopath
there's the one thing that I want to say
is like you you talk you know a lot
about like forgiveness and stuff like
that and and I I am so like I said
earlier like I'm so black pilled about
even being able to communicate with
people it's such and I maybe it just
struck me that like you're you're still
looking for ways to find EX to expect
good behavior from people or to offer
people the option of Behaving well uh
and I just don't think that they're
gonna yeah you know I'm obsessed not
really so Ben Franklin is a big
inspiration and that guy always had like
a twinkle in his eye and kind of a
knowing smile like we already won
um so he was like a diplomat yeah Ben he
knew the whole time he was like the
father of the Rebellion the father of
the United States essentially like
everyone looked up to him as a soul dude
how do you know he had a twinkle in his
eye did people write that down I I in
the pictures I've seen of I mean I think
maybe they do he was just yeah the
paintings and the stuff he just he's so
jovial and he's an inventor he's a
brilliant and like he knew his morale
was so high I think he just instilled
the morale of a Nation with his with his
books and his communication style so I
hopefully somebody people can do that we
got we got to jump to this story we got
this Twitter thread from Gonzalo Lira
this is the guy who was arrested in
Ukraine who has just recently gotten out
and is tweeting that he is seeking to
flee the country he says he was being
tortured in jail when he was arrested so
correct me I'm wrong you know you know a
lot about this Liam he's an American
citizen correct he's in America right is
coach red pill yeah yeah and and serge
if you bring up my pinned tweet is me
asking the state department about him
um in I think it was maybe like a month
ago or a couple months ago now
um and yeah I mean so that was when I
was at The Epic Times
um it didn't the the question didn't go
over so smoothly at The Epic Times I
don't know I don't know if I can get
into that too much well let's go through
this guy's Twitter thread he tweets
right now I'm about to um I'm about to
try to get out of Ukraine and seek
political asylum in Hungary and I will
also add this was from 6 23 PM it's
currently 9 24 p.m Eastern I'll check
his Twitter to see if he successfully
crossed he doesn't describe what
happened to him he says he broke no laws
he was accused of breaking no laws he
was just reporting on what was going on
in Ukraine and it made Ukraine look bad
so they arrested him he says my
indictment explicitly states that all I
did was discuss publicly known facts
about the war the epitome of free speech
and a democracy but zelenski's Ukraine
is no democracy It's A thieving corrupt
murderous gangster regime pretending to
be polite Western democracy he's right
about that and that's obvious because
Ukraine has always been that since the
fall of the Soviet Union
once arrested I was given documentation
assuring me that I was guaranteed the
right to contact my lawyers and loved
ones in fact I was blocked from calling
anyone even my lawyers and I was not
permitted to post bail he was going to
describe that he was tortured
and let me let me uh once inside he's a
prison I was tortured in the two of the
four cells I was in by the other
prisoners guards never beat prisoners
they outsourced the torture one prisoner
actually apologized to me telling me he
had no choice he wasn't lying I
understood I got a cracked rib in my
first cell but it wasn't too bad the
worst stretch is my fourth cell he was
going to say that he was beaten for over
30 hours and sleep deprived the craziest
thing about this
and uh this is pretty brutal so you've
been warned he says at one point two
thugs held my head and used a toothpick
to scratch the whites of my left eye
while asking me if I could still read if
I had just one
not gonna lie that was unnerving
he goes on to say the U.S embassy called
me three times but gave me nothing but
support in quotes empty bromides the
guard told me to remove my shirt he had
injury and bruising to his chest after
being beaten let's scroll down he was
going to mention that they found out he
had money he wasn't poor and they
extorted about a seventy thousand
dollars out of him and he's lost about a
hundred thousand dollars
he says the conditions of his bail were
that he has to wear an ankle monitor
surrender his passports and not leave
the city of Kharkov much less the
country however after posting bail he
didn't get an ankle monitor and they
returned his passports he was going to
say that he was told by one guy they
were telling you to leave and then he
says he's he doesn't know so he's gonna
he decided he will die trying he rode
his motorcycle across Ukraine one
thousand four hundred kilometers in two
days wow he said I'm going to Hungary to
ask for political Asylum when I fail to
show up in court in Kharkov an arrest
warrant will be issued likely an
international warrant no doubt other EU
countries will comply like sheep
returning me to serve five to eight
years in a prison labor camp
regardless of the fact that he have
arrested and imprisoned me for YouTube
videos for free speech what happened to
European democratic values well I'll
tell you Gonzalo Freedom Liberty in the
Constitution whatever you think you have
mean nothing in Warfare
they can tell you these things but it's
only when you're in a safe and secure
State while they allow it he says I'm
posting this thread just as I'm getting
to the Border checkpoint I'm also
posting videos on the two channels I
have access to the round table and
gonzalea again if you don't hear from me
the next 12 hours well I'm on my way to
a labor camp wish me luck I'll pull up
his account right now and see if there's
any updates uh that was that that I
believe that was the last he posted oh
my God maybe maybe he has some replies
and uh we don't know if he made it that
was three hours ago so this is a crazy
story this is insane and so this guy a
little bit more about him he was born in
California
um he's a U.S citizen he's like a dual
citizenship in in Chilean and a lot of
people use that to discredit him but he
was born in the U.S he is a US citizen
he was in the past like a contributor
for Business Insider Zero Hedge
um he I I've talked to some people like
who I trust and they kind of they kind
of have like a bad opinion of him
they're like oh he's kind of a wacko but
at the end of the day he was
um he is a US citizen and all he was
doing that is correct when he says that
all he was doing was making YouTube
videos
um criticizing the US uh NATO support
for the Ukraine war criticizing zelinski
um the you and I and so I asked the
state department about this a couple
months ago and and
um Matthew Miller the spokesman was just
like yeah you know we're aware this was
when he was still in jail he's like yeah
we're aware that he's that he's in jail
um we support free speech and I'm just
gonna leave it at that and I was like
well are you are you working to get him
released he's like I'm just gonna leave
it
and so clearly it sounds like Gonzalo
they probably well yeah
they might have given the order to get
him arrested but it sounds like he
escaped prison right if I'm reading that
right no they he was released and they
gave him back his passport oh really
yeah oh they released him gave him his
passport and said don't leave
however he was supposed to have an ankle
monitor and no passes I see okay so what
he tweeted which is what we were just
reading is that someone told him yo
they're telling you to leave
but it could be a setup like he said he
leaves he takes us and he says I'm
getting out of here before and that's
what they use to get him
yeah what do you do other than that well
this is wild and like I'm I'm excited to
kind of ask the government about this
now because like this could change
it's an interesting story like it's
going to be interesting to see how like
our government reacts to this because
like are they going to acknowledge like
are they gonna are they gonna even
acknowledge this story because because
inherent to it is the fact that they've
been letting this U.S citizen rod in
prison for a couple months you know
they're going to ignore it yeah well
yeah exactly but I'm and I'm I hope to
that I can ask him about it um and and
see what they say but it's you know
yeah it's just crazy I mean he had the
wrong views and and so we allowed um or
even maybe directed our Ally to imprison
him uh for speech I remember when he was
insane when he was making those videos I
was like in my gut I thought wow this is
what is he doing he's in a war-torn he's
in the country that's at War right now
and he's talking crap about his own like
that doesn't go well for Citizens if
you're in a war like yeah right but but
the U.S should still stand up for the
principles free speech I agree with you
I I asked Thomas Massey that this
question it was not recorded but he
basically said the same thing he was
like well what was he doing over there
in Ukraine but it's like he he lived
there he lived there before the war
started he wasn't only reporting he
lived there so what's this that was his
home what's like the the set like if an
American goes to another country and
becomes a citizen have they not just
forgiven all their American rights they
no longer have American rights no He's
still in this country's rights he's not
as well he's a resident
yeah he's a citizen of the US a resident
of Ukraine but his his U.S citizen
rights don't apply to other countries
like you can't no no but when but when
uh Chinese citizens but go Go I mean
listen to the Biden Administration
listen to the state department whenever
there's a U.S citizen who I mean
Brittany uh Brittany Greiner like
remember when she was detained in Russia
it was like all we could talk about is
like release him and then um they traded
the merchant the Wall Street yeah and
then the Wall Street journalist The Wall
Street Journal journalist who was also
in prison in Russia I don't know if he's
still there but it's like with those
things we can't stop talking about it
because there's our adversaries
imprisoning our citizens this is our
Ally who we have a ton of Leverage over
um imprisoning our which says to me the
likely scenario is the Biden
Administration ordered his arrest
potentially potentially I asked a bunch
of people in Congress about this none of
zero zero out of maybe like 25 I would
just I would go in the halls of Congress
and outside zero out of 25 even knew he
was in jail how plausible does anybody
does everybody here think it is that the
U.S government ordered him to be
arrested how plausible on a scale of
zero hundred I'm gonna go ahead and say
100.
100 uh plausibility I'm not saying it's
definitively true yeah well so what I
would say is like at a minimum they they
probably gave the okay you know what I
mean like Ukraine's not just like an
American citizen so they probably at one
point had the US and then Biden said
yeah sure you want to know why I think
the US ordered it because Barack Obama
killed a 16 year old American citizen
and that wasn't the only American
citizen he killed so when you can state
definitively that Barack Obama
murdered a 16 year old American citizen
a drone strike in Yemen then I'm like
yeah arresting a guy is like nowhere
near that bad I would say it is
plausible 100 that Biden could have
ordered that guy's arrest but I see Zero
evidence that he did so I'm not gonna
assume anything yeah exactly likely I
think no I am I'm gonna assume the U.S
and the US was involved because they
wouldn't get him out they wouldn't talk
about it they ignored it yeah it's too
we're too closely tightly knit with that
country to the us not to be well I agree
they were involved yeah I'm sure it was
disgust I'm sure they went and they said
hey you know Biden Administration we got
this guy he's an American what should we
do and they'll lock him up yeah don't
care probably because like Biden
probably doesn't care if people are
talking crap about the Ukraine it's
Biden you know he's checked out but
zielinski is like obsessively shutting
down radio stations into TV stations and
he shut down two of their biggest three
TV stations yeah he was doing that
before the war as well he was he was
sanctioning uh political opponents as
well as uh media Outlets that would
criticize him this was before the war so
yet another reason it's like why are we
why are we propping up this regime was
he doing that censorship with pressure
from the West
um I don't I don't know but he was doing
it yeah I don't I don't know where the
pressure came from but um
yeah so I you know he does have a
history of like not being a super
Democratic Pro Freedom Guy and um yeah
this story in general is insane I mean I
hope uh
I hope Lyra I I wish him luck and I hope
this also injects into like the public
conversation of like wow the us just
like let this guy rot there and like I
hope it opens up a conversation about
like you know that we're not really on
the side of of uh freedom and democracy
in this war all right everybody we're
gonna we're going to go to super chats
so if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends if you really do like it it
really does help and head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member at timcast.com to watch the
members only uncensored show coming up
in about a half an hour but for the time
being we will read your super chats Sean
says American flags number two song in
the country Tom McDonald and Adam
Calhoun make it number one absolutely go
to iTunes go to wherever you buy music
Amazon perhaps and buy American flags by
Tom McDonald
and uh let's let's uh build some culture
Tom does a really great job
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim I got too
caught up in our recent streak of
cultural winnings that I nearly forgot
when it comes to our political leaders
all we have are the hand sitting on
strong water yes hand sitting on strong
worded letter Republicans
but the good news is the Republicans are
sending more strongly worded letters
when I was I was getting worried for a
minute Rand Paul sent two so far hope
they gave him a chance to read the old
ones first oh yeah yeah
Brandon hampson says Ian is slowly
turning into ripped Jesus dude I look
good in the mirror I look good but so on
the strongly worded letters thing it's
like what what do people want them to do
impeach Merrick Garland they have the
house but can you do with just the house
you can impeach Merrick Garland yes oh
okay that conviction is something
different
okay that's a good suggestion so
impeachment and then you know but at the
very least we're saying just try instead
they're like oh you know what are we
gonna do what they're probably doing is
they're going to Democrats and saying
look they want us to vote to impeach
Biden but I'll tell you what I'll vote
no if you agree with my funding for
insert X Project right then they go you
got it that's it welcome to Congress
Cody Justin Fannin says nothing will
happen Biden will get a strongly worded
letter Congress is weak corrupt and lazy
I wish we had political leaders that
stood for anything
I agree I agree I'm not even convinced
Donald Trump is the passionate leader
who stands for against most of this I
think for the most part Trump had an
agenda he wanted to enact that he
believed in
what I'm saying but but I don't think
Trump's first term was him being like
we've got to purge the Deep State and go
after these people he certainly said
drain the swamp but I don't think he
actually passionately believed it
because he kept a lot of these awful
people in
I don't even believe uh that Trump cares
about it so much today I think Trump
Wants Revenge today big difference has
there been a leader that got in and was
like I'm gonna do everything for you
guys all the people the people then they
get into power and they're like yes
everything that people want and then
it's exactly what they wanted like all
of them Trump tried really hard to keep
his promises yeah but what I'm saying is
Trump had an agenda he thought was good
not everybody liked it he got an office
he tried to enact that agenda he did say
he wanted to drain the swamp he did for
some to some degree but he brought in a
bunch of bad people that were your
typical establishment Republicans but
then still tried to enact his agenda oh
poor him if only he just fired everybody
from the get-go and he should have done
it but but I remember at the time
they'll impeach him if he does yeah how
did that work out he got impeached twice
anyway yeah they impeached him when he
wasn't even president anymore
Matt H says Ian you're supposed to weigh
yourself after you take a dump in the
morning that's how you measure
approximate muscle gains yeah that's
what I'm talking about there you go Troy
Beast is anyone else excited to see
Tucker on Twitter change to Tucker on x
how's it going yep yep
Mac N says the UFO story is very old to
him not really a distraction but more of
a convenient time to bring it up
happened in the 80s have a good at night
guys it's a story that was written and
published today but I believe you are
correct it's about an old story what's
that what's that in reference to the
story that UFO uh almost started World
War III but I think that's a different
story actually I think the other story
was that all the nukes were disabled by
UFOs and now apparently there's a story
where if a UFO almost started World War
III or something like that
we are changed says Ian needs to take
the chill pill ashwagandha oh yeah it
helps boost natural testosterone and
helps with stress while working out Luke
rudkowski ladies and gentlemen we are
change what is that take the chill pill
thing that's Luke's uh
ashwagandha this is something take the
chill pill it's I've taken it before at
Luke's uh suggestion and it is fantastic
it's nice but does it have that issue
you mentioned of like needing to keep
punishing yourself I think so how did it
look like a supplement just I take off
for God how did Luke actually get take
her chill bill.com no no it just it just
relaxes you it allows you to calm down
and that's overall generative of
testosterone the chill pill take the
chill pill yo that's why in his his
personal one how did no one have that
domain dude go to take the chillpill.com
he says I'm here for watching Ian game
gain at some lean mass hearing 129 was
pretty shocking is Ian Crossland the new
Trad Daddy yeah 11 inches around think
about it Brad dad dude it was so weird
to gain 10 pounds in two days I've I've
weighed 140 in the past so it's not that
weird but that is very very underweight
I'm pretty so amazing have you checked
your checked your BMI no soon next time
I go to the gym we're gonna do a fat
muscle to be fair BMI is like a lot of
nonsense dude my BMI was seven and a
half percent when I went in the first
that's not what BMI is BMI is a number
like my body fat percentage percentage
it's supposed to be like hands yeah
between 8 and 12 I was seven
uh 23 or something 22 you are not 23
you're probably like 15.
been a while I think I got it measured
at the center as well if you work out if
you lift or if you're an athlete your
BMI is always super high so it's kind of
nonsense you know but uh for you you're
probably way underweight if you check
just do it right now you can take it
takes five seconds
let's grab some more Ryan Sergeant is on
a scale of one to ten what would you
rate the chances of the U.S going into a
depression 10 being definite P.S my wife
and I love rise with Roberto Jr
it is one of the best coffees I've ever
had that's uh over at castbrew.com but I
do think Appalachian nights is the best
coffee I've ever had it's easy for me to
say I'm the one who formulated it so
surprise I chose what was most delicious
to me and now I think it's the most
delicious thing ever but I really
recommend it uh scale 110 for depression
it's tough because there's a lot of
indicators suggesting things actually
aren't going to get that bad in the
short term uh it's weird things going on
but then I would also add the weird
things might suggest weird things you
know I can't I can't speak too much of
an economic guy I was just watching um
who was I watching what's his name
Anthony pompliano is that his name
professor's name yeah I was watching one
of his videos he explained a lot of this
stuff maybe I'm getting something wrong
but I recommend checking out his stuff
uh and uh I can tell you that when I
checked out Max Kaiser as a big Finance
guy all he did was scream buy Bitcoin
over and over again and then I regretted
not taking his word for it yep the
crypto makes it so it seems like a
full-on depression is less likely but I
think you're going to see a wage Gap
increase where you'll see some poor
people and yeah I know with the amount
of homelessness that struck the last two
years so there's a depression for some
you know apparently Gonzo Lira also
posted on YouTube yeah that's what it
says on that let me uh pull this up part
of me was like why is he posting but at
the same time like what in the hell
could anyone in that situation do at
this point oh I would I mean it's very
smart to record your journey and get
people yeah exactly that's the best
thing he would do just just for his own
safety just post something very smart
last thing you posted was two hours ago
saying he was about to cross the border
you should he should have live streamed
it he should have like twitch streamed
it should we could see what they did
should we Advocate to bring him to the
U.S and let him stay here he's an
American citizen
if he get on a flight he's here he'll be
he'll be safe yeah but then again if
Ukraine indicts him the us is going to
send him that's what I'm wondering yep
oh my BMI I have the number I I was 18.5
now I'm 19.8 oh okay that's pretty
that's not bad so
really you had 140 that seems really low
yeah I had a super low I mean I feel
like it should be lower
yeah I remember went to the doctor I was
the lowest number at the normal weight
which is 18.5
all gains from here on up just go to the
bathroom when you got to go to the
bathroom
sleep when you got to sleep yes and eat
twice as much as you think you need yeah
are you going to continue this pace
though of of what is it 12 pounds per
week
um I think I would be happy at 170. okay
and then just rip muscle just shredded
for movies movies like I don't want to
get too big
um but then I'll keep like a I'll keep
it stable after that so I don't know if
it means you keep working out everything
okay so you're you're okay right now
normal weight you know you're you're on
the low end you're on the low end but
you were underweight before yeah
yeah 129 yeah Gandhi yeah and so yeah
that's like amazing
um actually even at your lowest
apparently you were just at the bottom
end of uh normal weight at 127. Luke
says uh 127 is underweight Luke's is in
hitting the gym let's go uh let's go in
dude Luke let's get out of get out here
man you're gonna love it real quick on
the depression brother real quick on the
depression thing I so definition of
depression is uh three or three or more
years of sustained decline in the real
GDP at at least 10 percent
um in one given year so I mean is that
possible
um potentially I mean that would that
would just be very devastating I don't I
I disagree with you I don't see how
crypto in any way prevents
you know affect GDP if anything is
taking money away from GDP because
you're just like putting it into these
computers that
um solve math problems and give people a
fake coin I think I see a lot of
benefits to crypto what do you mean fake
coin well I just mean it's a it's a coin
that isn't backed by anything but it is
it's you know it's the immutable Ledger
but it is well especially depending on
which coin you're talking about well so
what I was going to say backed by US
Dollars okay but then you know if it's
if it's backed but then but if it's this
is the thing with crypto if it's backed
by an asset then you are now relying on
a third party to honor that commitment
you mean like like buying silver yes
well no you but also you can buy silver
and keep it at your house so so but the
point of crypto and you can Cold Storage
crypto
um no yeah you can Cold Storage crypto
I'm just saying if it's backed by like a
US dollar if it's backed by an asset
that then you're relying on someone to
actually give it to you um one of the
cryptos I do like is Monero that one is
like
I don't even own it but it's like
all the transactions are like obfuscated
so they're all washed and like you know
so the government can't track you and I
think there's some there's some utility
that like if we did slip into some sort
of authoritarian world where your
transactions are being uh monitored and
stuff and you want to use something like
Monero I don't think it helps GDP
um I don't know if we can go into
depression
um but I do love Peter Schiff check him
out he's great there's some econ stuff
yeah he came to an Occupy Wall Street he
would probably agree with that I think
he thinks his whole thing is he thinks
we're getting a depression and inflation
and it's going to be freaking bad
because we're in stag inflation right
now as well all right let's read some
more it never happens around and we're
already in this we've had so many never
happened things so a lot of economists
say they know what's gonna happen there
there there's no way no no we got it
says an expansion of the idea of the
truck company segment earlier uh just
for a quick reference yellow trucks is
shutting down 30 000 jobs about to be
nuked 22 000 Teamsters UPS was founded
by its Union to have made 52 billion in
profit in the past five years and UPS is
now giving about seven dollar raise to
all drivers made me thought think why do
we demand more in Pay instead of demand
company drop prices
well the the staff they want the people
who work there want to get a bigger cut
of what they're producing that I get the
issue with yellow truck is that the
company was collapsing and the union was
making demands and then the company just
outright collapse and now nobody has a
job
so the point I was making is that it's
really funny how when it comes to the
left's arguments they're like the people
who are producing the product deserve a
share of the wages and I'm just like you
are correct and then when the company is
facing debt do we take that money back
and they got to pay into the company to
cover the debts no so they only get they
get they get profit when the Going's
good but when the going is bad it's
everything on the on the business that
doesn't make sense does it
all right how about this like here's my
here's my negotiation everybody gets a
percentage and then when the company
falls on Hard Times you have to pay to
reinvest back into the company
yeah no one's going to want to do that
right
all right we'll grab some more Jacob
says listen to Tom McDonald and Adam
Calhoun's new song American flags indeed
you should
we'll grab some more Super chats here
sh22 says the reason why the USD keeping
its strength up is because of
geopolitical economic interdependence
keeps people on our side if they have a
vested interest in the US that's right
the reason why the U.S is giving money
for gender studies in Pakistan is
because if people have the money they
want to use the money so the US is like
we will bolster confidence in our money
by giving our money away
there you go
that really does work that way yeah 's
helicopter tour says Tim that makes no
sense why would the CIA to avoid
communist China becoming strong prefer
the globalist Communists at the wef CIA
is badam okay I can explain that to you
very simply you see the world economic
Forum people in the CIA Democrats the
Deep State they took a look at China and
said their system is so much better than
our system because they can spin on a
dime we want that we just don't want
them to be in control
they want the all of this live in the
pot and eat the bugs they just want to
be the ones running it it's that simple
they don't believe in the American dream
and American values they believe in
power I see it a little different I see
three factions on Earth the the
Communist faction the economic faction
and the Liberty faction okay you could
say that the CIA has been co-opted and
that it's not quite functioning as a
liberty faction right now but this
liberal economic border when were they
ever yeah really 1949 hopefully 1942 or
43. I know it was always like Alan
Dulles I don't think Alan Dulles was was
ever about Liberty well then the Spanish
uh American war 1898 they legit
liberated Cuba and just like Cuba but
the CIA didn't exist in uh that was that
was the liberal that's the liberal ethos
that I'm looking for oh okay the the
sustaining the Monroe Doctrine
um so I do I think that there's multiple
factions I don't think the ca
necessarily wants the world economic
Forum to take over either but they're
just they're blind with their pants down
like how do we stop technocratic you
know Revolution so I think their ears
are open all right Cipriano Diaz says hi
Tim my cat is having surgery tomorrow
broken tooth fractured Paul and Joe oh
no everyone please pray everything goes
well Ian please send some healing energy
for quick recovery love you all love you
I hope everything goes well I gotta give
you that rock Luke charged it in the
ocean before let's do it we got to grab
it ceremoniously yeah he walked into the
ocean with this uh Crystal
and you wanted to make sure you knew
that he charged it for you X I have no
idea what that means but he put it in
water so he put his Reiki into it his
electromagnetic field vibrated the uh
subatomic spin within you put it in the
ocean oh and then he said it's charged
now the ocean charging oh maybe those
are free radicals ionization from the
charge you gotta like bring it back to
the uh the Waters of Tijuana
um yeah I think so it could lose charge
but some structures are so so great at
holding charge like crystals
Group B says went and saw sound of
Freedom yesterday morning for first
showing at 10 40 and it was packed I
re-watched the Tim Ballard episode dude
what a story that that is actually I
would recommend that
if you go see sound of Freedom go
re-watch the episode of ir we do with
Tim Tim Ballard as like a director's
commentary almost or go see the movie
again then go watch the episode we did
we did with Tim Ballard again so you can
get a breakdown and it's fresh in your
mind and uh what do they break like 150
million I think is that what it was let
me use at this point now let me pull up
sound of Freedom no I haven't seen it
yet so I I'm I'm planning to yeah man
um
249 million wow Jim caviezel's got like
this this silent amazing pain the man is
is amazing I still haven't seen that I'm
a Passion of the Christ yet well so what
I thought was funny about sound of
freedom is like when the mainstream
media bashed it his q and on
um everyone who liked the movie kind of
jumped to its defense and it's like no
no it doesn't even talk about the
government and that's when I was like
well okay I'm not as interested now I do
realize it's like super up what's
going on but like
um and I think a lot of pizzagate was
but there was a lot of weird
um factual things in Pizza gate that
raised red flags about John podesta and
stuff so I I would have been much more
and then obviously Epstein is a proven
case of of basically government
sanctioned pedophilia so I was
um you know I hope I wish the mainstream
media was right and it did actually get
into some government uh pedophilia you
should you should watch the passion you
should yeah yeah I watched it recently
for the first time I'd never seen it and
uh it's good it is it's not uh it's it's
I I don't actually see it as overtly
religious it's very political is it just
caviesel screaming at Agony for like two
hours not really okay I think that's
exaggerated I mean it's a merciless and
graphic you know I like the politics
Jesus Christ Superstar the musical also
good politics it's a lot it's a it's a
lot of politics it's a lot of you know
like the I've I remember strongly the
scene with uh with with Pontius and he's
talking to the crowd and there and he's
you know like all of these things very
political I thought it was very very
show Judas from like a somewhat
sympathetic light like in Jesus Christ
Superstar they kind of show the stories
from judas's perspective and he's
watching his friends slowly lose it he's
like Jesus when we started it was about
the message now it's about your name
they're screaming your name they don't
care what you're saying anymore this has
got to stop and Jesus is like ah he's
who's in his mind it's an awesome music
they show throwing the silver it to
Judas and it like spills in the ground
yeah wild and then he like throws it
back later and he's like yeah I know you
should watch it it's interesting
all right we'll grab some more Super
chats over here
let's see Eric Miller says Tim about
Yellow trucking it is rumored that
Amazon and Home Depot were gonna buy
them because they have accounts of them
and it's cheaper now interesting
Robert fox says I don't normally get to
watch this live but let me cook I want a
Roberto Jr shirt that says flock around
and find out keep doing the great work
cluck around and find out oh yeah let's
do it cluck around and find out I get
flock around and find out I don't know
maybe that one's better
we're going to be doing
um Roberto Jr pro model skateboards oh
sweet yeah like I I'm not I don't I
don't get a pro model skateboard I mean
you know I posted a skate video today on
Instagram I like that because it showed
a blooper that was cool it was it well
it was still impressive the blooper made
it better because I saw like the
struggle it's not it's not so much a
blooper and it's it's that day I did a
hang 10 hardflip late flip stuck it and
then fell and that was the best it was
gonna be oh that was awesome and then I
did a different trick which is very very
similar which is an endo flip Oh I
thought it was the same trip trick two
different tricks okay two different
tricks very very similar so the first
trick is called a Hang Ten hardflip late
flip the board flips around then right
before catching it when it's upright I
hit it again so it flips one more time
on the grip tape the second trip uh
trick is a Hang Ten Endo flip where the
board flips end over end and then
halfway around I hit it on its Underside
while it's upside down causing it to
flip one and a half times and then I
land on it different trick
look so much but yeah I'm not a skater
but it did look cool I gotta say that
Roberto Jr pro model that's sweet yeah
do you know what size she's gonna have
like Roberto Junior's probably gonna be
A5 yes because that's the board I'm
gonna ride the Roberto Jr
yeah he's a superstar over here man you
know he's like all the ladies love him
yeah all the chicken ladies
they love him but little Luke's been
been going at it lately little Luke the
rooster his feet are all messed up oh
yeah yeah just because he had bad he uh
I think it might have been
um
malnourishment something happened when
he was a baby which is like earlier this
year and so his feet are kind of messed
up but it's okay because apparently he's
had no trouble you know getting it out
with the ladies well that's good are you
going to have a a single that's good a
single Bowl to get the ladies uh
typically we just have the we we for a
while it was Roberto and Roberto Jr and
then Roberto you know he had to be he
retired yeah he was actually imprisoned
for uh sexual assault yeah he was
hurting one of the hens pretty bad and
now Roberto you guys put him in prison
it was culture he had to get put in a
separate little pen because he was
hurting that oh wow and then Roberto now
he's over at the uh town over at
Freedom
um but uh Roberto Jr now his Spurs are
really big and he's starting to hurt the
ladies pretty bad so he's taken after
his father well it just happens when the
bruises get older and a lot of people
are like cut the Spurs and I'm like ah
but that's mean like it hurts him and we
don't do that but maybe we just got
Roberto Jr is gonna have to go to uh
finer pastures I think what we're gonna
do though and this is a big announcement
we're going to auction off a bunch of
the chickens they have a chicken auction
here radically out here and so we've got
too many and they keep making more of
themselves so we have to do something
about that so we're probably going to
take you know a good portion maybe half
of the current batch and then auction
them
so I think the people locally out here
will be really excited and then we'll
get like little placards with their
names and we'll like sign it like
officials cast you know uh cast Castle
chicken City chickens but then we'll
keep the original chickens those are our
those are our friends you know we we
like them like Margaret Martin Roberto
Junior Margaret's very ravenous
let's grab some more Super chats from
our friends here
's nalorem says you are all talking
about Russian prisons but in America we
were talking about Russian prisons we're
talking about Ukraine but an American
presence people get raped to the point
it's a joke in most media and pop
culture think about it the worst crime
in existence even murder is more
merciful happens in American prisons as
standard fare if you cross a warden by
refusing to be uh literal slave labor
yes the U.S U.S prison system is
horrifying and completely broken I agree
but we were talking about Russian
prisons yeah I don't think we said
anything about Russia no we're talking
about Ukraine yeah Ukraine Brittany
Greiner came up at one point oh right
right right right right okay yeah but we
didn't mention anything about the
prisons or endorse American prisons
either so yeah as doe is to Dear says
there is no faster way to accelerate the
divide in the country than to pardon the
leader of one side after they commit
High crimes I agree yeah you have to do
both at the same time nope wait sorry
can you say that again this was the uh
no faster way to divide a country than
by pardoning one leader like a leader
from one side of the political aisle
and then and then Prosecuting someone on
the other side yeah hour or not pro yeah
assumedly I guess I really think I
really just strongly disagree with you
about about uh
like pardoning people and stuff like
that I really think what's your
motivation for it because like on the
whole blackmail thing to end the Ukraine
war I think it's a no-brainer part in
them but like
um I I don't know I don't think so that
makes no sense if if it if it had a
chance of ending the war in Ukraine I
would do a lot of things but I would
certainly pardon Joe Biden yeah um my
goal that is right but but that's that's
okay if it would do thing we do it sure
but like the reality is it would not no
no it might be because he might be I
might have blackmail on him and that
might be why we're still you have pardon
power for in this position you
criminally prosecute
like that there's no circumstance in
which you'd pardon Joe Biden for any
reason
uh
what do you mean that the re the reason
is like if you can you can forgive him
and say don't worry Joe Biden as
President we the American people will
not hold it against you if it turns out
you did bad things yeah yeah I see yeah
if you are the president and you have
Federal pardoning power you go to your
doj and say lock him up I want an
indictment tomorrow morning right so in
yeah okay it's not technically pardoning
it's basically just like we're not gonna
prosecute him well I'm looking for her
but he but but no he has the prosecution
power like well right he in scenario was
like if you're a president or like if
you have magically have the pardon power
would you use it to you know and this is
my point Nixon let's talk about how we
deal with this in reality because this
scenario is impossible completely
impossible right you have to win we need
ballot harvesting ballot chasing we need
massive voter operations Trump goes in
appoints uh on AG who immediately goes
after Joe Biden and we get a perp walk
there you go prom song but like that's
also fantasy like if you you think
that's gonna happen like you're not no
that's not that's actually possible no I
see it's like a physical it's a it's a
theoretical possibility I just think
like the fact that not only Trump gets
in the white house but that he like is
able to these are just opinion
statements right I'm saying it is a it
is a fact-based reality that
Trump is running for office right there
may there's going to be an election
if he wins he can then appoint an AG who
does his thing there is no basis in
reality where someone magically has
pardon power but they're not in the
government yeah no I I get what you're
saying I'm just saying like you yourself
said that like you think the 2024
elections are going to be they're going
to happen but they're basically going to
be a sham and I didn't say that I said
no one's going to accept the results
oh I see okay so you you actually so you
think there's a real chance Trump could
win yes
well to answer your question about oh
you have more well like Trump beat
Hillary Clinton right but then like
think about 2020 when there was the
whole Intel Community coming together
and being like in and censoring the
hunter Biden story
um you know and they created the the
Russia story during the election as well
against Donald Trump right and Trump
still beat Hillary Clinton yeah and I
mean because Hillary didn't go to what
was it she like skipped Michigan or
Wisconsin I think it was I think it was
actually Pennsylvania but I'm not
positive or somewhere in the restaurant
I guess so you don't you don't fully buy
into the fact that like they they will
do whatever is possible to not let them
get him in office avengeful second term
Trump you don't think that the Deep
state will yeah I didn't say that but
but what do you think is more likely do
you think like the Deep state it will
succeed in preventing him from getting
elected or do you think like what's what
do you think the percentage I think I
think the the bureaucratic State the
Deep State the permanent government will
do everything in their power to try and
stop Trump and there's a possibility
Trump wins do you want put a percentage
on it that Trump wins
no idea
we have no idea Trump won in 2016 he
lost in 2020 so that means it's 50 50.
50 50. okay I give it a seven percent
chance
I like that yeah anyone that says I'm
gonna I'm gonna one you hire me to be
your boss I'm gonna fire you they're not
gonna hire you to be their boss uh the
reason I'm going for pardons and why I
keep talking about pardons is because I
don't honestly I don't give a about
Joe Biden Donald Trump Hillary Clinton
these old people that have been
shredding my my Republic for the last 20
30 years these families I'm tired of it
all I want to wash them away I want to
Pardon everyone let them retire so we
can create a new government a functional
yeah from their retirement they buy
houses next to the White House start
putting tons of money into their
appointees use their exorbitant assets
and their hundreds of millions of
dollars earned from their influence to
then inject people into your new
constitutional republic that that'll
never stop though yeah it will it's
called putting him in jail yeah but that
doesn't stop the behavior like
and it also pisses people off when their
relatives go to jail so you just got to
be careful with that I am the whole
process very I have very little concern
for corrupt American Dynasty families
who have been selling us out when
there's 320 some odd million people who
would smile if these people were locked
up for the crimes they commit I'm not
convinced that that
I'm talking about the babies too because
a lot of those hundreds of millions of
babies in there babies smile too I don't
think it's a good idea to worry about
the the reactions of family members as
when it comes to whether or not we
should prosecute people for violating no
no politically we gotta go to the
members only yeah so we're we're going
way over we got it we gotta go to the
members only show so ladies and
gentlemen head over to timcast.com
become a member because that show's
coming up in a few minutes you don't
want to miss it it'll be on the front
page of timcast.com smash that like
button subscribe to this channel you can
follow the show uh at timcast IRL you
can follow me personally on X and on
Instagram at timcast I just post a
little skate clip over on Instagram and
X
Liam you want to shout anything out
um yeah you guys can follow me on
Twitter X at uh at Cosgrove underscore
IV and um that that's really about the
only place
I am Phil Labonte I am
Phil that remains on Twitter I'm Phil
that remains official on Instagram the
band is All That Remains you can follow
us on Apple music Spotify Pandora the
old YouTube I'm Ian Crossland you guys
follow me on x x.com Ian Crossland I
know you guys are playing XCOM speaking
of video games earlier yeah one of the
best video games ever made is that one
of the isn't that like a freemium game
XCOM UFO defense premium alien probably
at this point it is it was I came out
and buy Microsoft micro Pros in 1992. I
would be shocked if that's the best game
ever it was really good dude and they
made sequels I've never played it I have
a feeling elon's a fan he's got x.com
nice job everyone uh nice work bringing
it to the Forefront brother so come on
over to timcast.com we're gonna do a
little hot after show action I'm gonna
convince you why you should pardon
Hillary Clinton you're gonna be into it
you're gonna love it I disagree I don't
think you should pardon Hillary Clinton
of all people my name is serge.com uh
I'm really proud of you gaining all this
weight getting shredded bro for real
um pleasure meeting you Liam and uh yeah
let's just do the after show let's go
for it we will see you all over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out